[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to fat man be out I'm Kevin
Smith I'm muckman holy [ __ ]
let's address this right away make a
bunch of money this is a gift you got
one two - Kevin - mark you get your own
little baby Yoda from Kelsey and Derek
who are you kids where are you magical
kids [ __ ] name as Christmas hat these
are gorgeous look at you are you selling
them anywhere let's see the [ __ ] out of
this man the whole world's looking to
get their hands on a baby Yoda you got
one right here but change your address
yeah [ __ ] Jon Favreau himself will
show up this is beautiful man thank you
for this
[ __ ] well done I got a gift already all
right kids everyone in the room see the
movie here just for shits and giggles
anyone not see the movie good yeah so we
could be frank and [ __ ] like that before
we dive into anything else - anybody see
SNL last night Saturday Night Live how
awesome was [ __ ] Eddie Murphy man I
feel like a child right whole episode
was just fine he seemed to be having a
good time
[ __ ] more of that every year they should
end with him hosting an episode if he'll
come back he was I know we just had it
and [ __ ] but I'm like do it again he was
so [ __ ] good it was great and there
was a bunch of [ __ ] that like only Eddie
Murphy could get away with yes
have you heard of me - yeah you like
hose me - yeah head like [ __ ] did he
just huh all right
they seem to know it to man they were if
I could make it jokes about it like
throughout the whole sketch come on like
Twitter's gonna be mad and [ __ ] like
they pulled it off they pulled it off
but he was just fantastic the whole
night man
I loved that well I think it was in
maybe the first sketch he cursed and
they bleeped him out oh he said [ __ ] by
accident yeah and then you sort of look
and then after that [ __ ] it I did it
once what are they gonna do to me like
he comes out like Gumby curses a couple
times like I don't care now I may never
come back I don't have to it was joyous
and joyful and actually like one of
their strongest episodes like of the
decade man it was really top to bottom
and I laughed out loud quite a bit I
mean they I suppose when Eddie's gonna
be your host everybody brings their a
game yeah you know well you know the
whole world's gonna watch them so if not
live when it happens afterwards like
every guest star wants to show up we got
him like who's the biggest musical act
in the country we got her like we're
gonna make this [ __ ] funny let's do it
we're only gonna do this once you guys
don't show your ass in front of Eddie
Murphy unless he asked you to in which
case there's an after-party he he's he's
referenced of course he was there for
Dolomites pretty reference being done
with coming to America too I know there
were a lot of there's a bunch of people
I saw on online last night who are like
or this morning actually I read the
reactions where cats were like now I'm
looking forward to coming to America too
I never got out of the eddie murphy
business yeah how were you not yeah it's
funny to hear him talk about it though
he seems to have like stepped away just
to have the family mmm children yeah all
right I mean I guess when you're that
[ __ ] rich the the reasons why most
people stop out the children don't apply
anymore
yeah you know like I'm sleepy don't
marry a teen Manny's I don't have money
for college I have 48 million dollars in
my pocket it's like
you could literally have an army at that
point it was well fed and well led and
anymore if we could do those things it
was it was great man it was a just made
me feel young but like one of those
things that like I've been on the road
with Jay and Silent Bob reboot and a lot
of people like the movie makes me feel
like I'm a kid again and that Eddie
Murphy on Sara alive had that feeling
for me I was like oh this is what I felt
like when in the 80s when you were like
I got to stay up man who's he doing
tonight Gumby [ __ ] this is amazing and
he did them all like he did everybody
except James Brown but like yeah yeah
that was the one thing I was like I
wonder if but man no complaints it was
just [ __ ] great he seemed to be
enjoying himself even at the end like
when he came out the end he was just
like ah ha ha maybe so happy what else
is there anything else before we dive
into what we're here to talk about I
don't think so
let me you got anything no I don't think
so
I didn't make it out to see cats today
which I wanted to they haven't sent a
screener oh you're never getting a
streamer yeah rewards contention like
please vote best [ __ ] what was the
what was the what's been the just
general consensus is god no I the joke
agendas is you need to go see this
either like really really tired really
really drunk or really really high
preferably all three at once
but have everything is that there now
apparently shipping new prints to
theaters because this special-effects is
[ __ ] up
there's they like forgot to replace Judi
Dench's human hands with cat hands and
they were like oh that's not a choice
that was an axe
yeah we [ __ ] that up and apparently
there's like a dude in the sweatshirt
just banging around in the back scenes
and they're like oh we forgot to take
that dude either out completely or this
sweatshirt and so like universally
shipping new prints to theaters fixing
the special effects
I mean after why it's better with like
the human hand yeah I mean maybe that's
the like that's how you drum up interest
so like you can [ __ ] catch the cut
where we [ __ ] up apparently Tom Hooper
who directed it who had previously
directed won an Oscar for the King's
Speech wonderful movie wonderful but
honestly not like I wouldn't think like
the King's Speech give him cats yeah he
did lemis before this alright well there
you go right then and there I would have
been like don't give him cat like blame
is was it was wonderful but it's [ __ ]
depressing it's a little depressing I
mean yes as I recall it as a bunch of
like like [ __ ] people loved that show
some do a lot of joy now and forever but
on lame is like when you're shooting a
musical and you have your cast singing
they're recording their things on stage
to what's called a click track so that
you can synchronize all of the people
all of the singing all the moments in
every camera move you get all that [ __ ]
right tell me about filmmaking mark I
will
[Applause]
I'm lame is Hooper's like [ __ ] your
click track I just wanna record it live
which made all the post-production
impossible yeah because you couldn't get
any audio sync so it took them forever
to post that on this movie it was like
well okay we're gonna CG all the [ __ ]
cats in right it's just gonna be like
actors on the stage and it will press
the cat button and they'll suddenly turn
it to cats it's like so we don't need to
put anybody like mocap suits or little
dots or nothing and we don't need any of
that do we should do that right tom nope
and they did so like that's why people
with like [ __ ] human hands and cat
hands were like if we have the dots on
the hands we don't know what to replace
that but you didn't want to do that so
now they're spending their sparing no
expense shipping new versions of movie
into theaters it seemed like you know I
like the thing about that show and
they've been doing it like for 1,100
years at this point and not just in New
York like all over the [ __ ] world you
know you put some [ __ ] makeup on a
[ __ ] and throw some whiskers on
him and they do this [ __ ] you're there
yeah it seemed like they went through a
lot of unnecessary expense to do
something that has been done perfectly
acceptable and wonderfully for decades
now it just felt like we got to use
technology and sometimes you know
sometimes like [ __ ] wearing a leotard
would work man
it's most fake tale and I [ __ ]
reach out to the furry community
see how they do it but this just seemed
expensive from the first moment I saw
this [ __ ] I'm like [ __ ] this looks
unnecessarily expensive it's like they
just wanted to buy a house in the
uncanny valley yeah and and like live
there full-time what a great analogy man
it's [ __ ] true though like yeah no no
are you sure you want to be in the
uncanny valley but like that's exactly
where we want to be we want to be
unnerving like I went out of my way to
make tusks unnerving the human walrus
like that shot where is it that's like
that was me trying my hardest they just
made a whole [ __ ] movie full of cats
man and it looks equally under
to be honest with ya and it's for
children no no I heard that it's all
about sex all these cats wanna [ __ ] yeah
I mean a their cats so sure right it's
almost like rabbits but like this really
shows the stereotype for cats I don't
think your kids is like [ __ ] like when
I think of [ __ ] animals definitely
rabbits for sure yeah on the dogs
because they'll like hump your [ __ ]
leg there's I just want to [ __ ] calm
and like it doesn't matter but cats urge
every v'n seen a cat [ __ ] you yeah was
that like you're lying or is it like uh
how can you not it's so hot
I've never seen cats [ __ ] I neither have
I'm allergic to cats [ __ ] so I don't
think of amazing thing come is like
animals that like [ __ ] a lot but like in
the musical apparently they're illicit
all I want to do is get the memories are
of just previous [ __ ] of having
having come a few times yeah back to
good times and should be what that songs
about I've got I might be honest I never
really had much of an interest in going
and I do like musicals so it wasn't
necessarily that I'm just cats it's not
my bag but that first trailer sealed the
deal and I really hope that you know for
their sake that it got better but it
sounds like it only got worse I just I
want to see how you burn a hundred
million dollars and apparently it's you
make cats and I want to watch the flames
will I do business is it doing any
business
the final box-office scores I mean the
projections were not great I'm hearing
reports of like I'm sitting in an almost
empty theater that's like an old couple
sitting like nine rows in front of me
and it's just us that's some yoga hoser
[ __ ] right and you know we didn't spend
that much money to get to that end
result so there you go [ __ ] that's a
shame man that's a lot of loot that's
like it's like a lot of food for a lot
of people if they're hungry and instead
cats
all right so that was going on this week
wait that opened against rise of
Skywalker yup
I mean what the [ __ ] kind of like hubris
is that man but like you know you know
that [ __ ] cat's trailer that everyone
[ __ ] hates double down on the [ __ ]
you car we're gonna open opposite the
movie the whole world wants to [ __ ] and
see who did they think they were gonna
pick up the old couple speak up for us
we are the old couple and we all went to
see [ __ ] of Raisa Skywalker wow man
that's that was silly I could have told
them no on that one I mean maybe they
were like listen whenever we released
this movie it's gonna like make no money
be [ __ ] on so at least let's do it now
so we have an excuse that's actually the
benefit ejek choice with like oh we'll
go out on the same day as cowboy you're
like you'll get killed they're like
we'll go out the same day as Skywalker
[Laughter]
have gone wrong cuz that's right it we
all just found out but they knew months
ago oh yeah
when did they know and who knew they'd
have known for a while like there's
gonna be problematic ya know like by
July like oh no we've seen this movie
guys yeah they're like let's just take
the money and run I'm going out on the
day the same day as the Skywalker I
guess makes sense but through that prism
anything else come out anything else
foolhardy enough to even I jumped off
tour once any of this movie was coming
up I don't think which by the way like
we never really got to talk about it I
was on tour I never saw Joker the whole
time really I die no go [ __ ] me in the
mouth how did I not see it
guys got a show called Batman Beyond I
didn't get a chance but I never I would
let me tell you something hmm
movie I have seen yeah Jay and Silent
Bob reboot a lot yeah yeah here what's
up oh [ __ ] it holds up for me and [ __ ]
but I never got a chance to break away
and see Joker I did get to watch Joker
blu-ray [ __ ] Warner Bros ourselves
out of blu-ray god bless him and I'm my
big-ass TV which as big as a movie
theater screen anyway [ __ ] so a theater
of one me by myself [ __ ] movies
[ __ ] good
man right did you not like it you [ __ ]
on that movie oh my god what do you want
man that's the movie we all dreamed
about his kids like when you read
complex like could you imagine if they
treated this [ __ ] seriously and someone
made like a hardcore [ __ ] Joker movie
they legit like did it man that movie
went hard no it went very hard and you
still weren't happy Jesus I can't wait
to hear what you think of this movie
this Star Wars picture [ __ ] did you come
out and say that when the movie was out
there in the world
uh-huh was I here No thank god man oh
they did the Internet try to kill you I
mean no more than they usually do
it was AI mean honestly like [ __ ] a
quantum leap forward for him as a
filmmaker like and he said some
ridiculous things in the press on the
way up to the lead-up of that movie to
the point where you were like not
necessarily rooting for him but like
that movies so legit wonderful so
[ __ ] good that you're like my hat's
off man like [ __ ] it's that's [ __ ]
well done
it works on a couple different levels
works this comic movie works is not a
comic book movie shed I've got zero quit
Wow one quibble I thought it was long
you well you must have thought it was
really [ __ ] long as you didn't like
it I thought it was like you could have
done with liking and I can't even say
get rid of this scene but like it just
felt 15 minutes chunky I'll tell you man
I've you seen honey boy yet no honey boy
is wonderful has nothing to do with like
this genre or anything like that but
it's [ __ ] fascinating incredibly well
acted wonderfully written brilliantly
directed and [ __ ] great across the board
it's worth watching biggest praise I can
give it 90 minutes long like [ __ ] she
makes her point gets the [ __ ] out man
like he's a bad dad I get it like if
they had one for like awards length and
one for the two hours it just would have
been another half hour of like what a
prick you know but like at 90 I was like
I'm good I'm full it was
[ __ ] well-done and [ __ ] so Joker felt
a little long and [ __ ] me what do I
know it made a billion dollars but like
just in terms of length that that's the
only thing I'm like he probably could
have cut it down and the ending the last
last piece I was like you didn't need
that like when he was out of the make up
in the hospital right cuz I thought him
on the [ __ ] cars and they were all
like wow I was like Jesus Christ this is
gonna win every [ __ ] award imaginable
look at this like I'm ready to paint my
face and join the movement like it's
unbelievable it's a rallying cry and
then suddenly without the makeup I'm
like oh they're trying to win awards so
there's that last [ __ ] scene somebody
I can't say who told me somebody [ __ ]
told me cuz I know this is out there
maybe it's on the internet did you hear
what the ending was supposed to be I
don't remember I might have but I don't
know I hope this is [ __ ] true man
because I was like what the [ __ ] like
this is what I was told by somebody who
works in the business and they're in the
know and he's [ __ ] super smart and a
great storyteller and [ __ ] and I don't
know where he got it but it's reliable
information Bono if he's supposed to
share it so I don't know if I'm supposed
to share it but [ __ ] is too good to
[ __ ] not share so I don't want to
give the person up okay and maybe
[ __ ] this is completely wrong but if
it I [ __ ] hope it's true
originally the movie's supposed to end
with him in that room because I was
talking to this person about like I
didn't think you needed to him in the
hospital at the end I thought him on the
[ __ ] cars felt like the end of the
movie it was insanely triumphant so I
said originally the ending in the
hospital was different I don't know if
this is true or not but I [ __ ] like
when I heard this I was like oh I about
calmed myself and that's saying like
this movie's already like classic as far
as I'm concerned but then what might
have been and who knows if it was just
in script but here goes so he's in the
hospital and he laughs chuckles and the
lady goes what's so funny errs and he
said I just think of something funny
what was supposed to happen was you
flashed back to
the death of Thomas and Martha Wayne
and it was him killing Thomas and Martha
Wayne and the boy was screaming and
crying and he turned to walk away then
he turned back shrugged and shot the kid
credits what the [ __ ] man could you
imagine like that's that's literally a
biggest [ __ ] you to the audience it's
like this world has no Batman it's just
all [ __ ] Joker's I was like that's
Network [ __ ] deep man that's [ __ ]
so intense I would have been outraged as
a Batman fan and elated as a fan of film
as a you ballsy [ __ ] oh you did
it but they didn't do it and still it
was a good [ __ ] movie man but if they
had done that would you have liked it
more a little bit a little bit although
its relationship to the Batman mythos
was part of my favorite part of that
movie like watching the kid go down the
bat-poles
yeah like the kinetic blows that it sort
of worked coming although i zoom in and
out I'm not like it not enough to pull
me out of the movie or [ __ ] this movie
but I really like winced or my [ __ ]
tightened that mean Thomas Wayne like
Batman's dad being a prick who you're
like [ __ ] him I hope he does get shots
coming out of a theater you know like
normally we're always presented he's a
good dude he raised a good kid and that
kid went on to do good things and stuff
so presenting him as this piece of [ __ ]
at first i chafed against but then at
the same time I'm like wouldn't that
make your kid even better if you were a
big ol [ __ ] and [ __ ] wouldn't that
also explain like Batman a little more
all of it was just like to me like I sit
there and think about I honestly don't
know if I'll ever watch it again and not
because I'm like oh the artistry I mean
he's [ __ ] amazing like he's worth the
price of admission alone Joaquin of
course they'll [ __ ] give him all the
awards and [ __ ] like that but I don't
think I could [ __ ] and do better than
that [ __ ] first viewing I watched it
oddly enough the day my dog Louis died
and I was in the worst place ever to me
it was a very that movie picked me the
[ __ ] up man that's weird to say about
Joker but like I was in a blue blue
space from the dog being dead but I took
my mind off it
two [ __ ] hours and change yeah I
thought it was something not you all to
go back and listen to buddy yeah I am
glad you enjoyed it Kevin see ya
[ __ ] man like you got a high bar what
else do you want from these people man
[ __ ] it was good
just like show hands man how many people
liked that movie Joker how many people
did not like that movie Joker did not
see Joker put your hands together
[ __ ] spoils spoilers thought everybody
[ __ ] saw fine I thought I was the
last guy in worth watching all right
shall we
we shall how many times have you seen
this movie I've now seen it twice in
theaters I went to the premiere and saw
the premiere then I went to the Chinese
Theatre and watched it on opening night
Thursday night the very first show that
lining up buys the theater out foreign
stuff Clare King from Allegiant M
brought me in and showed me something I
had never seen at I had no idea existed
at the Chinese there are secret booths
laptop Sid Grauman's booth where he
would watch movies and there's a [ __ ]
bar attached to it a separate room for
parties and [ __ ] like it's crazy the
whole time I'm going there for years for
movies and [ __ ] now they're like you got
your hands in the cement [ __ ]
come upstairs oh my god I was like what
the [ __ ] like I'll never be able to just
go to the Chinese anymore I'll be like
yo you got any more that booth action
left well I can look down on everybody
like Cersei at the end of Game of
Thrones and [ __ ] sipping your wines
oh this improved everything [ __ ] and
then they they played trailers before
that show premiered just goes into it
premiere had the benefit of being
introduced by like JJ who I thought was
absolutely [ __ ] magnetic funny
wonderful and [ __ ] like that
and then he had the old cast there and
stuff and there's like ice yet there's
[ __ ] Steven Spielberg so there was
that aspect of it the lining up net
screening had enthusiasm love ogres with
lightsabers
turn the lights off and bunch of cats
turn Chu now and they all have sound now
and should so you heard him all light up
it was really kind of sweet and and
people were just ready man and then they
showed a bunch of trailers which was
weird because it's like you want to get
right to it but then they showed [ __ ]
Tennant the first eight minutes a tenant
which eight minutes is that what it was
how long was that I saw it five whatever
I was thinking didn't they do that for
dark night oh no no the trailer I
managed and I was like wow does this
[ __ ] dope man this looks really good
oh he's making a movie he [ __ ] with
time and then I thought when they put it
up I'm like oh we're gonna see the
trailer in in [ __ ] what's that's
formatting IMAX and [ __ ] but instead
they were like here's a bunch of movies
they showed you their dick man like
[ __ ] he didn't hide nothing he was
like look at that [ __ ] and reach of
this and just flopped it out I felt bad
for any movie that had to follow five
minutes of that movie because the whole
audience like soon as it ended it was
like bomb had that [ __ ] hans zimmer
scored [ __ ] and it said tenant whole
[ __ ] place was like wow i ripped the
[ __ ] roof off and [ __ ] so i saw it
there then i saw it at home twice
because they sent out the academy
screener the day the movie opened all
said I looked at my envelope and [ __ ]
and it was like the movie I was like oh
my god I'm gonna watch the [ __ ] out of
this so I've seen it now four times how
many times you see it
so twice so when opening night okay at
the ArcLight in Sherman Oaks okay with a
bunch of [ __ ] nerds because who else
is going opening night man I'm gonna put
[ __ ] baby you're the right where you
can see him so maybe you don't go so
[ __ ] cold I could feel it already
look at that dude you can't not like
that that's your childhood man as a
child right there and I saw it again
last night I took my son okay so you got
two viewings under your two views on
your storytelling man in your fan of the
genre and a fan of the series you've
been there for all of them my the
longest relationship I've had in my life
barring my immediate
family is with Star Wars right I saw it
when I was seven and now I'm 48
so almost 41 years in with this [ __ ]
franchise you lining up your bona fides
doesn't give me a lot of confidence
right now the second viewing went down
easier than the first okay because
because my heart had already been broken
so that the pain didn't sting quite as
much it is it is it is hard to talk
about this movie independently without a
talking about the balance of the saga
mm-hmm and be tortured as the undone be
able to ask offending not just a movie
yes attending a trilogy and ending a
song an analogy yes that's one and
ending a lot of a lot of people's
childhoods yes but it also comes out the
same year that another giant franchise
found a way to wrap up 20 chapters of
story time you're gonna pull the a card
aren't you at the same time and both of
those challenges are incredibly
difficult like that's a hard [ __ ]
bird to land yeah like you've got scores
of characters you've got lots of people
have their favorites lots of story
threads need to be wrapped up lots of
emotional things need to happen in order
to make it feel like it had been worth
the trip right and and to a certain
degree I feel like Star Wars for me
became less about the characters in that
drama as it was about us at home
watching that drama and so the
relationship that I think JJ has
specifically is with fandom not with
Luke and Leia and Han and Rey and Finn
and Poe and so things that happen in
this movie happened to make us happy as
an audience but not because it's what
the characters need to have happened to
them to make that story work right
example there's a moment at towards the
end of this movie we've all seen it not
gonna spoil anything
yeah spoilers if you're watching at home
nothing but spoiler
the mud spoilers when po and the rebel
fleet are on the worst name planet ever
x-- ago and and all hope is lost right
like like they're getting their [ __ ]
asses kicked
the fleet's about to take off and and
like all hope is lost and then there's a
crackly voice coming over a headphone
and that voice says we're all here with
you buddy there are more of us and then
you look up in its land oh and a [ __ ]
bazillion space every ship ever created
every ship ever created now po has no
idea really who Lando is maybe he's
heard of him once or twice in like
passing or whatever well you met him in
that one scene right so yeah we know who
you are but he has no emotional
connection to that character so when
that character shows up it means kind of
nothing to PO that it's him
it means everything to us as an audience
because we have a connection to Landon
right so but watching just like in
Return of the Jedi he's gonna save the
day he's gonna save the day and now when
you look at a movie like endgame which
also has your hero all hope is lost
standing on the field of battle
everybody around him is like dead and
here's a crackly voice in his ear and
it's on your left and that means
everything to that guy like to Steve
Rogers that is the world not just us the
audience and we're all still there for
it but it's Steve Rogers that means
everything to him and then the billions
of ships that show up are his friends
who show up and so that moment has just
nothing but emotional resonance and
we're all crying and he's crying and
he's [ __ ] straps a shield in and then
there's a hammer which is awesome like
everything works there and then in that
moment in rise of Skywalker I was just
like it's missing the things that I know
it's trying for because it's doing the
thing that they just did literally
note-for-note and and it doesn't work
and I feel like a lot of this movie is
giving us things that we kind of think
we want and we get them and they're less
interesting than a thing we didn't know
we wanted and are surprised by you know
like Palpatine okay sure I mean
I guess if you need to have another boss
for kylo Ren to have to find a way to
you know refute sure the last movie gave
him his own Emperor which he killed and
did the thing and now he's the supreme
leader so he's the bad guy we built an
entire trilogy of movies where he's
going to be your bad guy who now needs
another boss and that boss is a dude
that we killed three movies ago and now
we're gonna invalidate the sacrifice of
Anakin Skywalker just so we have a name
recognition of this dude and actually if
you think about it you know they're
always like this is the Skywalker saga
but it's like in pure minutes of screen
time it really is the Palpatine saga cuz
he was all the prequels and Luke wasn't
no real sky I mean Anakin was but my
[ __ ] it feels like it maybe more
Palpatine at the end of the day man yeah
so they were just like I I just found
myself wanting it to go deeper into
itself and be its own movie and find its
own drama and lean less on the stuff of
old to build something new and then
burning and then end it and then send it
off on its own happy ending but just as
a whole I just kind of was like this is
how we're landing this bird mmm and I
was a little it was shallow for me
compared to Game of Thrones ending um
because you were not you were I was not
that either but at least that found plot
ways to at least like pay homage to the
characters even though it also was still
a little too heavy fanservice scene like
and and again fanservice is not a bad
thing like giving fans what they want is
is valid but it's the things that they
don't know that they want is what makes
you happy and finding a way to be both
surprising and inevitable is what you're
hoping for and not again to refer to
endgame but when cap gets [ __ ] me on
there that's everything because oh [ __ ]
of course he can do that we kind of set
it up for movies ago yeah and it's he's
[ __ ] worthy he's worthy
we know he's worth we've watched him
prove himself worthy and so when he does
it it becomes as validation of your
fealty to that story hmm and they're
trying for that moment here when like
raised throwing Luke's lightsaber into
the fire and then Luke's hand reaches
out and grabs it it's like I I know but
you know like at that moment had less
like that felt more like there are a few
moments obvious moments of Ryan
correction ryan johnson correction in
the movie or [ __ ] you ryan like is what
it kind of feels like of course the
biggest obvious one was in the trailer
we probably talked about is him putting
his mask back together because you know
ryan got rid of the mask he's like
pocket and then JJ immediately put the
mask back together but that moment there
what was that moment we were just
talking about when force Luke catches
the lightsaber especially when he's like
you know a Jedi's weapon deserves way
more respect than this I felt like a
real like you know hey kids it's Mark
Hamill's lecture my god you know and
which is really JJ's lecture of just
like you know we shouldn't have done
that in the last movie or whatever there
were a few of those moments including
they reference like whole though at one
point somebody was like hey man what do
we tried the whole blow maneuver which
to me I'm like [ __ ] yeah worked once do
it for like more movies go ahead like
keep it doing it [ __ ] just sacrifice
a ship each time but somebody was like
now the only works once and you're like
why let's go deeper in the conversation
but to be fair I remember seeing last
Jedi and you know I was like well why
can't Luke get off the planet and go to
you know Craig or whatever the [ __ ] and
they were like because man the [ __ ]
his ship is in the water and I'm like an
and they're like well because he's got
no astromech droid and i'm like yeah but
only because Ryan didn't give him one
like if he wanted to give him one he
could get there and let's be honest he
didn't need any of this [ __ ] can't he
just be like the [ __ ] force took me
there [ __ ] which they eventually kind of
do so you know at the end of the day
like you know when he comes to this
moment the movie where he raises the
x-wing even that felt like [ __ ]
you Ryan I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna take
your plane out of the water and we're
gonna use it to get into the third
[ __ ] act but like even even that
moment where you're like okay we're
going back to this planet we're gonna
have this conversation with Luke he's
gonna set us on the right path and then
we got to give his x-wing out of the
[ __ ] swamp right clearly who gets to
do that of course that moment in Empire
where Luke tries and fails yes is
indicative of him not being able to be
the hero he needs to be he's going to
fail against Reiter because he can't do
this thing it's the it's the the Simon
signal that he is not ready yet to be
the hero he's going to be yes in this
moment in Ray's story she is the hero
she needs to be to move this along so
why doesn't she lift out the [ __ ]
thing for us for us but also because we
want to see Luke do it because afraid
did it a lot of people would be like
what the [ __ ] why didn't they let Luke
[ __ ] raise it cuz that would have
been so mental cuz he couldn't do it an
empire like with the moment they did
that honestly I felt the movie was
satisfying and gratifying for that
reason because anytime I was like they
better alright they did that oh they
better not satisfying and gratifying
takes every box it's satisfying to us as
the audience but not to the character in
this story because that is the moment
where she is proving herself worthy of
being able to take on whatever bad guy
is going to be at the end of it well
it's Luke II and I've Luke say how am I
supposed to get there I have the ship
and then you see it [ __ ] lifts out
and then you see him smile at her and
she does it because she's got the
[ __ ] force she's the diet whatever
that [ __ ] is yeah that was kind of
the midi-chlorians of this movie man
toss it out there real quick and rolled
over it so yeah like it's just you the
the feel thing you have as a storyteller
is to the characters in the story and
you're hopefully telling the story that
the audience will respond to but you
can't like it I mean yeah I love
cheeseburgers and so on I go to
restaurant i order cheeseburger I want a
cheeseburger but if like I go to a
restaurant from a chef that I trust and
like yet bring me something I'm gonna
love and you're supposed to know what I
like and give me something I didn't
expect to get and like you ever do that
do you ever go to a restaurant they like
surprise me
and a [ __ ] rich man [ __ ] is that
how sucking yeah hock dude one percenter
you're like I don't care
this [ __ ] feed me I I'm a Hollywood
elites it better be endangered suppose
it's the normal good today give me some
of that I had a different experience
with it I enjoyed it
like I said satisfying gratifying I
yelled a bunch during the movie which I
was reminded by I saw somebody on
Twitter said I enjoyed the movie more
cuz I sat in front of Kevin Smith he
kept screaming the whole movie and I did
every time they did a fanservice thing I
was like yeah like [ __ ] when I don't
know how I was the first person but like
as soon as you heard the voice go hey
kid like I was like no [ __ ] way
Disney must have so much [ __ ] money to
pull this off oh my god they had to pay
him a king's ransom to get him to show
up man but he [ __ ] sure enough there
were Sam soon as we saw a han Solo
if I can everyone applaud it but on top
of that as soon as the applaud was dying
down I was like [ __ ] yeah JJ and then
people laughed I felt good but I had a
lot of moments like that fanservice even
I learn about moments I love that moment
because it again it's it's helping to
turn your kind of second hero of this
saga on the right path and I love that
he ends the last word han Solo says in
all of these movies is I know yeah yes I
saw that and heard that too I was like
and it's which is kind of a great way
like that was his I love you yeah to his
mom so him saying it - that's him saying
it to his kid I liked that scene so much
I think that boy such a good actor Adam
driver he's [ __ ] more of a man than
I'll ever be
homeboy he's younger than me yeah a war
Calma kid he'd is part of many wars and
[ __ ] in real life not just an illusion
[ __ ] I thought you met the Star Wars and
those two go mark those aren't real
he's real good man like he's such a good
actor that he could like sell some of
this [ __ ] and he really sold that scene
with with Han which to be fair going
into this movie I was like they better
kill the [ __ ] out of kylo Ren for what
he did to Han Solo piece of [ __ ] and
then once he's with his dad I'm like oh
man they're bonding yeah and I like how
everyone kept calling him Ben I was way
into that man like [ __ ] how she kept
differentiating where he's like offered
you my hand and she's like I was looking
for bad you know it was all came down to
like Ben's a different guy how awesome
to be able to [ __ ] literally kill
planets full of people and then be like
oh that wasn't me that was kylo Ren I've
been the good guy who wears sweaters
from the gap you know like we can make
out before I die because I'm good old
Ben man but pay no attention to the
night of Ren who just [ __ ]
slaughtered people and [ __ ] left and
right that was the one time I think I
might have ever sat there in a movie
theater and I lifted of the middle
finger and shouted [ __ ] you kiss that
kiss I don't know see at some point that
like internet infected me and I became a
reloj shipper where I was like oh yeah
they could work as a couple I'd never
saw that when I saw those movies had
never occurred to me I'm like well she's
the good guy and he's the bad guy never
the twain shall meet
but i guess the obvious play is like
well [ __ ] love wins and whatever the
[ __ ] and that's story i guess it's easy
to tell if it's that same familiar note
but i don't know you could tell that
same story if finn is the [ __ ] hero
and kylo ren is the bad guy and [ __ ]
they fall in love that would be a ballsy
[ __ ] Star Wars right there but I
didn't I didn't have a beef with what
with them kissing what I honestly i sat
there going like when they kissed I was
like yeah
like a bunch of the Internet's gonna be
happy and then I was like oh but a bunch
of the Internet's gonna be mad and then
he dropped dead and I was like he won
the entire Internet like he's he got him
all man like they kiss they could have
been lovers but he's dead and he
deserved to die because he killed Han
Solo he's a [ __ ] but I thought he it
seemed like a lot of check in a box it
seemed like fanservice across the boards
and ways of like what did I like let's
do that
like [ __ ] look I'll be honest with
you movie could have like sucked all the
way right till when Chewie got in the
metal and then I would have been like
that was worth the trip man I've been
waiting [ __ ] 42 years to see somebody
recognize the space dog you know and
they finally gave him his medal he's
like [ __ ] I was there too but it wasn't
even his medal it's if I read that
moving less medals not ladies medal she
didn't get one ounce man Hans medal
which she would have because he passed
away so I like that a lot when I had to
deep thinking cuz at first I was like
well how many of these medals do they
got and how long did they wait to be
like it's been [ __ ] 42 years give
Chewie a melon and then I was like no
and then I knew it wasn't her medal I
knew she was holding it when she died
and that's what I thought was kind of
sweet because she was holding Hans medal
and that like I'm gonna get emotional
that like for her that was the greatest
moment of that too it's like she had a
kid she had you know with this [ __ ]
and [ __ ] but like the greatest thing he
ever did was that like piece of [ __ ] was
like I'm in it for the money man [ __ ]
your war and he took off and he the
greatest thing he ever did for her was
not like kissing her or [ __ ] marrying
her or [ __ ] like then becoming a
couple it was when he came back and
[ __ ] saved her rebellion so her
holding that medal I got real [ __ ]
emotional when I figured out that's Hans
mental and I didn't get in till like the
third viewing I was like she's clutching
his medal to her heart that's so [ __ ]
beautiful the that that the medal is
then passed on to Chewie is really
[ __ ] sweet because it's Hans medal so
it's like you get the double hit out of
that [ __ ] medal and it just irritates
me and nobody thought to do it until
this moment and he did it right before
the credits but I was happy it [ __ ]
to happen at all cuz it wasn't something
I knew I wanted but when he did it I was
[ __ ] of course you would have to do that
because I talked about it on a podcast
for years and [ __ ] there are lots of
little beats like that
Admiral Ackbar having a kid jr. I
thought that was [ __ ] sweet 9 numb
being in the battle wedge showing up for
another [ __ ] battle the Battle of
icicle or whatever the [ __ ] it's called
ex ago
what else did I like there was I think I
thought the beat here the beginning felt
oddly choppy to me like I tried to think
about it was there ever a single Star
Wars movie that opened with a montage no
every Star Wars movie opens like the
crawl finishes and we're in space like
in Star Wars you pan down and there's
the tain't Eve and then there's a Star
Destroyer and we're into the movie it's
a scene Empire Strikes Back you're
watching the words then it's the probes
I remember correctly and then we're down
to half and if I get in the move it's a
senior in a [ __ ] scene Return of the
Jedi it's the crawl then do we go down
to Tatooine and it's the droids
no it's Death Star so you're in [ __ ]
space and it's a scene it's the Emperor
Emperor showing up or something
Darth Vader arrives on the half bill
[ __ ] new Death Star [ __ ] it's been a
minute man
so boom you're into a scene I can't
speak for the prequels because like I've
gone through a lot of therapy to burn
him out of my photograph no no I just
don't I just don't know them quite as
well Dave Filoni would slap me for
saying something like that but this was
the first move even in the new movies
you know he start in space and then you
start your scene this is the first time
where it was like you start with the
crawl and then you come down to like a
planet and then there's like a slow-mo
montage of like kylo Ren porn like him
just killing [ __ ] people and he's got
to do something there that's where it
gets like [ __ ] oscillation
overthruster the trick and then he goes
to another [ __ ] place like it was not
a straight-up seen at Felton
it felt like it felt choppy felt like
probably the opening scene was that
killeth on which one
was an actual scene or whatever and that
got compressed into this montage affair
and stuff that was the first thing I
noticed I was like oh we're not in
Kansas anymore we're not doing things
normally and I remember in interviews he
was talking about like I feel free to
break off for him and do you know do
whatever and [ __ ] which he did how did
you feel about Ray being Palpatine's
granddaughter um I'll be honest with you
I liked you know I respected what Ryan
was trying to set up where it's like
you're nobody like [ __ ] know you're
[ __ ] you're not part of it like I
thought one of the coldest [ __ ] lines
in that movie was when I forget it
exactly what the words I've been last
Jedi when he was like you're not this
isn't about you yeah you're not special
yeah like [ __ ] you're not a part of
this you're just a [ __ ] scavenger
like that was dope man I was so like
that was like [ __ ] was his name
[ __ ] uh whose Duty was in James
Spader in pretty and pink like remember
that character he played he was always
just like yeah I was just so shitty
they're all name blame all the bad guys
in those movies named Blaine oh my god
[ __ ] it was just so cold and [ __ ] so
I liked what he was doing but I'll be
honest with you when he did it I was
like oh no she better be [ __ ] related
to somebody like why am i I'm in this
story otherwise she'd better be invested
this is the Skywalker saga and [ __ ] like
that so you know I always assumed Ben
Kenobi and then Ryan did what he did the
second movie and then I knew they were
gonna retcon it into something because
people largely didn't seem satisfied
with her not being connected to a
previous character and so when they
chose Palpatine I'm like honestly the
first thought I had was he got laid like
kylo Ren I think he died a virgin man
[ __ ] and Palpatine somehow got laid
like that seemed weird and that he had a
kid and that like the kid like his
rebellion was I'm going good and [ __ ]
off like as opposed to be part of the
Empire show like that yeah I that I was
fine with it I mean they had a connector
to somebody but like but do you think
there's something super nice about
anybody could wear the mask Yeah right
like anybody can be here oh there's one
[ __ ] Skywalker yeah I know but it's
the Skywalker saga I mean he gets to do
a hundred movies about people who are
force sensitive and [ __ ] that aren't
part of like that nine movie saga that
George Lucas envisioned and stuff so I
don't know like I I get what they were
trying to do in last Jedi and I think
it's cool and stuff but at the same time
I want fanservice I did want her to be
connected to one of the other characters
I never imagined it would be [ __ ]
Palpatine man had somebody told me like
oh she's gonna be related to Palpatine
I'd be like Holmes just make her a
scavenger please like [ __ ] we've had
enough of that character but boy he came
back man that was there's a [ __ ] ton of
Palpatine in this movie yeah there was a
little amount of Palpatine
lots and lots Palpatine um I didn't mind
it though so much that that's she had to
be related to somebody you know clearly
it wasn't gonna be Luke and Leia and
stuff so I don't know I think a Ben
Kenobi would have made more sense I
think maybe he didn't get laid either in
us in a saga where there was literally a
virgin birth where like this is all
gonna start you know the force had a
baby because which didn't Palpatine
technically I mean like if I remember my
Star Wars history prequels correctly
Palpatine technically he was the one
that arranged for the midi-chlorian he
he didn't have sex with her but he was
responsible for Anakin's it's canon
where did they talk about it what is it
it's up to interpretation yeah I thought
the idea was that like Palpatine was
responsible technically for the creation
of Anakin Skywalker I mean that ain't in
the movies in the movies
Shmi Skywalker she's like I had a baby I
gotta [ __ ] nobody and that baby is this
little kid
and it's like oh that should have been
the title right there movie would have
made so much more money right like the
idea that the force knows that it's an
out of balance and it is causing the
correction of said balance so why
couldn't that have been the same thing
with Rey why couldn't she he just had
been some [ __ ] girl on a jump planet
from nobody who the force decided was
going to be the one to bring balance to
the force that's how this goes and you
still have a Skywalker Ben Sola was a
Skywalker and you're going to redeem him
by the end cuz these stories are always
about Redemption so you still get to
have a rise of Skywalker and the movie
still get to be about a Skywalker and
without it being that person
oh so [ __ ] I always forget he is a
Skywalker so technically the title they
get two bites at that Apple it's not
just like her gone I think I'll steal
his name but that also kind of might
know who she was who she honoring there
cuz she saw Luke and Leia on the clouds
like his forest ghost Malcolm XI and see
kylo Ren he disappeared and he did good
[ __ ] at the end right yeah I mean by by
the standards set by these movies asking
you what was it kylo Ren there as if
you're gonna have a good answer for
[ __ ] no I was already against the
movie it would have been you know cool
if he was honestly the one thing I
wanted to see in the movie the thing I
said was like if JJ could pull this off
he [ __ ] wins forever is to put all
three of those in one shot and they got
close and I guess for reasons like well
technically Han Solo wasn't a Jedi so he
would never force ghosts but I'm like
yeah but only because you say that like
you could literally have made him a
force ghost and yes there would have
been some people being like he can't
really be that but they're already
people pissed off anyway right might as
well give everyone what they want put
those three [ __ ] standing next to
each other and there's your own credits
in [ __ ] oh my god they would push all
the Oscars on but he got close he put
them all in the same movie they were all
he did were you surprised that Harrison
Ford showed up I was surprised although
like they kept that real quiet kept
super quiet
yeah maybe Yoda quiet and it's like [ __ ]
and that's like my second favorite scene
in the movie is him with his right yeah
and I love the bit but the one bit of
this movie that actually got me teary
was when Chewie learns about Laius oh
yes [ __ ] yes first time I saw it it
didn't register second time I was like
oh he's rather emotional and then the
third time I saw it I was like that
guy's crime from the weight of like
everyone I know is [ __ ] dead man I
don't like any of the new kids oh my god
I'm gonna go eat some [ __ ] pork just
the last person I knew oh that was
heartbreaking a which is that he wailed
and dropped to his [ __ ] all-fours
I wanted to live in that moment for
longer yeah like I wanted to be with
[ __ ] like thoroughly distraught
Chewbacca and like I think Lando like
comes in on the tail end of that scene
and they're like we're gonna launch ever
[ __ ] we didn't know what we were
doing we were young like what Lando and
Chewie both reckoning with the death of
Leia would have been lovely because
they're the last two people who like
rolled with them when they were kids
yeah I give Lando a bit of that moment
but let it be [ __ ] Chewie agony more
of it give me the pain I honestly and I
did feel more based on Chuy's reaction
than I did feel when Leia died first I
was confused first viewing I was like
wait what did she do
she like did she use her life force like
did I had to piece this together myself
I was like did she cast her [ __ ] life
force across the galaxy the way loose
Luke cast his [ __ ] you know village
and what did she do exactly make him
like you'd be good for five seconds like
is that what that was or just she imbued
him with the goodness of herself and
that made him stop long enough for him
to get killed which was satisfying I was
a gasp I screamed out when that happened
I was like [ __ ] you I was happy to see
him die then they check the other box
where the login' gonna die she gonna
[ __ ] heal him with that Wolverine
healing magic and [ __ ]
watch that wound close-up and then I got
it like you know it's good that he was
like oh you [ __ ] healed me the force
can be used for good like [ __ ] you
can heal people with it's right I mean
it feels like Leia found a way to reach
out to kylo and that's what a loud way
to kill him which what yeah like it's
because when was that lay as intention
when Leia Donna holds his hand so that
he gets killed I it's super unclear part
of that problem is that you don't
actually have an actress to do the other
side of that story in that you know
you've only got what little they had of
Carrie Fisher right from the production
or force awakens and I'm sure there was
some stuff left over from from last Jedi
as well so you're you're trying to like
thread this really difficult you're
writing around the footage that you have
right and so you don't you can't get
what is your take away what is my take
away is that when she dies Ben feels it
and that's what stops him from attacking
her then what did she do kill herself I
cuz she went with purpose to lay down
and and didn't like Maz Kanata say like
she's trying to reach him or something
right but she gave some exposition he
heard her voice yeah she didn't
disappear until he did the let's go with
it like she's dead she let's go with a
metal rock Jessie's got microphones
stand in the space and you know you
buddy what do you think yeah what was
your take Reed at that moment even
though unless Jedi Leia says there's no
good at him Luke go kill him no mother
is gonna you know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna distract my sons to that new girl
who I hugged and said a Chewbacca when
my husband died can kill my son
that's silly it's amazing nobody did
that some people won't let anything
[ __ ] down so carrying that grudge so
wait so but you didn't answer the
question what was your what did she do
in that moment I
I think she just reached out to him in
and hey I'm your mom be food I'm going
to why was he here
star wars movie where she's like she hey
I'm your mom she
kylo was obviously conflicted there
anyway and that scene mirrors Anakin's
demise in Episode three anakin turned to
darth vader in a river of lava with lava
waves kylo turned to Ben solo in an
ocean with water waves he was because
that mean these reasons that mirror is
that there's Leia reached out your the
scene with you could just say I don't
know because if she could do that why
hadn't she done that every [ __ ] week
for their balance of her life like but
like I did was make this call then he'll
be cool again give a virtual hug that's
all the kid wanted man that's I thought
it was a virtual it was somebody here
Erik Carrasco who wrote episodes of
Supergirl he's been here on the show
he's working on Masters of the Universe
with me we were talking about and Mark
we were talking about the movie and he
goes and he's one of these like you he
proves the thing where you're like [ __ ]
why didn't they do that and he said
wouldn't it have been cool if how she
died was bringing Han back for that
moment like that she is that what she
did get on a [ __ ] microphone where
people could see you because kylo says
you're just a memory it's not your force
ghost yes
it's you're in my head and so Han says
I'm only telling you what you already
know yes I think in the same way that
like Luke projected himself across the
universe at the end of last Jedi yes she
sends him Ben as a sort of like last
message but but that's what she does is
she she loses her life by basically
creating a last vision of Han that's my
fear I mean that's like look if that's
it then I forget him think that's great
but I didn't get that read I didn't get
that until Eric told me that and I was
like holy [ __ ] that would have made it
so much better like she died
pulling [ __ ]
han Solo to them because that's the real
Redemption right like where he sits
there and has that conversation and they
repeat the same [ __ ] that he said on the
bridge where he's like I know what I
have to do but I don't know if I have
the strength to do it and then so all
you need to have happen and then he
throws his lightsaber away and then Luke
shows up and he's like a Jedi's weapon
deserves more respect on that but for
that to work what you then need for for
Han to say is like you're just a memory
no your mother sent me to you that's all
you thought I'm sayin one line that's
what Eric said he's like one more line
and you own the audience hearts he had
another [ __ ] moment like that where
he's in the movie what is the character
that Finn meets who's also used to be as
John Connor who honestly felt like wait
shouldn't Rose Tico be doing all this
stuff like written they should be doing
a lot more than she's doing yeah yeah
that felt weird it felt like they
introduced like new characters and was
like like even like it's one thing is
use Ori and stuff like that that's posed
backstory but felt like like at the very
least Rose Tico could have given us all
the information that the Hobbit guy gave
us like The Hobbit guy like every once
in a while pulled me into another movie
where I was like wait what am i watching
like who's why huh and him my god
eventually because I'm like oh he wasn't
Dominic mommy and he was in lost and JJ
did loss so I get it but it feels like
every line he had you might have wanted
to let rose say cuz only she didn't
really have a lot to do and said she's
like I think the shields are up captain
like she's a hora for like three scenes
in that movie and then she's got a gun
in the last scene which is kind of cool
but yeah there's a lot more screen town
that could have gone there there's a
moment there like Rose you coming and
she's like no I'm gonna stay here
and I'm like I don't know that's what
the roads I met in the last movie would
have done but whatever but wait so there
was the moment he said was all about
Jana he's like you know she reveals that
she was also a stormtrooper like him and
you know he go and that we were all in
this battle and we they told us to kill
civilians and we all put our guns down
we all mutiny didn't [ __ ] and he goes
all you have to do is write one more
line to make that emotionally resonate
and I was like what's the line and he
goes you need Finn to say because he
says in the movie why'd you do that
and she goes I don't know we just all
did it and he goes all she has to say is
and I'm gonna cry saying we heard about
you yeah cuz he did that in the [ __ ]
first movie Erik said that I went and
kissed him on the face forgetting that
he didn't put that in the movie and it's
not in the movie I was like that's so
[ __ ] beautiful man like that he his
[ __ ] would have resonated like that
three movies later that thing that you
did like you are the rebel you are the
resistance like [ __ ] you're not just
the guy who's like ranked aback I have
something to tell you to tell you tell
me what it is that's okay
JJ apparently I looked online JJ out of
screening somewhere at Q&A afterwards
said what he said I he said he dropped
the ball he cut something out and so we
didn't ever find out what Finn wanted to
tell her and it's that he was force
sensitive which we see throughout the
movie so they felt they could lose that
and the audience is pretty bright and
they wouldn't put her together but I
think JC has something to say the the
theory that my friends and I had
afterwards about I don't believe I got
to tell you this but move into the
[ __ ] yeah the new the new n Dorian
defectors yes is that all of them are
force sensitive and the indoctrination
of the first order didn't take because
that will be the New Jedi Order or pass
on what you have learned will
will spawn from Finn and that group of
defecting stormtroopers I smell a Disney
Plus show right there man
we cooked Lando says he's like where you
from kids she's the hot dog no and he's
like well let's go find out and then
nothing happens and I was like what the
Oh
Disney Plus that's where we're gonna
find out this saga will never [ __ ] it
let's go find out as we [ __ ] a lot on
this [ __ ] we're sure maybe we're all
reading something into it like oh that's
a new Disney series and JJ is like no
he's just hitting on her and it's weird
that's that's a cool thing man like cuz
you could spend more time with that
storyline a little more time with that
storyline talking about that connected
to him that would have been amazing so
what's with the horses and how cool
would that show be why explain to just
Finn being the captain of the New Jedi
well he don't wanna he's already John
boyega said he doesn't want to do a Star
Wars show for Disney less well then it's
Lando and the lady that's amazing and I
think you just came up with the title
right there the lady ever lady lady in
the [ __ ] second draft order yes you
know there are definitely moments but I
think I could do that with every Star
Wars movie I'm still to this [ __ ] day
really [ __ ] like and I'm I know I'm
right and it's not just like some
[ __ ] fan theory but Return of the
Jedi I've talked about it probably here
Return of the Jedi the Emperor's sitting
in that chair he's like I feel your
hatred grab your weapon and strike me
down he literally taunts the kid into
doing it the kid does it but then like
[ __ ] there's the Emperor and I'm Luke
he gets it and he goes for a frontal
[ __ ] attack and of course darth vader
[ __ ] blocks the shot who [ __ ] goes
for a frontal attack against [ __ ] darth
vader this is the [ __ ] the evil
Wizard of Oz he could do [ __ ]
everything in she'll like that
I always thought from nineteen [ __ ]
eighty three to this [ __ ] day man if
he had [ __ ] pulled that [ __ ] and then
went around if he just did a circle and
came behind the
and then cut that [ __ ] in half we're
done it's all over [ __ ] like and then he
talks to his dad and [ __ ] credits
it's all good and [ __ ] that's why I'm
last Jedi went [ __ ] like kylo Ren was
like oooh and [ __ ] dope got [ __ ]
stabbed drink I was like that guy's
brilliant man because he had an idea
that I had when I was a child your force
sensitive oh [ __ ] man me and him alright
wait what were we talking about
oh so anyway there's a lot of [ __ ] that
I could be like I'd fixed this or I'd do
this I still feel like the time for
Princess Leia to die in those movies was
in the chair instead of Admiral hold Oh
in last Jedi imagine how powerful that
is this girl who we saw from the
beginning fighting this [ __ ] endless
[ __ ] war and [ __ ] like that if she's
the one that's just like the only way to
save this rebellion is to give my life
like that's that [ __ ] [ __ ] wins
Oscars
now you could backseat drive these
movies all day long and stuff like that
so you know it doesn't really pay to do
that kind of he's fun but it doesn't
really [ __ ] make the movies any
better and [ __ ] like that
so you judge the movie you got and I was
satisfied with the movie I got I was
like look they gotta end it he checked
every [ __ ] box I felt good about
things I was hooting and hollering they
brought back everybody I care about if
only for one [ __ ] scene and stuff you
know they gave Chewie a medal what
[ __ ] more do you people want like
[ __ ] that was it that's how I felt I
will tell you the one last thing that I
wanted all right I wanted is this you
rewriting it is maybe right now goes a
little bit there's that line that Luke
tells her when you're forced Luke's like
a thousand generations of Jedi live in
you now yeah and so her entire arc of
the movie is you know trying to connect
with those generations be with me be
with him which I didn't get until the
third viewing when she was just floating
in the air gonna be with me I was like
she's trying to reach that kylo Ren [ __ ]
you man like he killed Han Solo trip but
then it was third viewing I realized
she's trying to reach out to the Jedi
because Princess Leia or general
he says it like [ __ ] like she said
over a says I can't hear all the jedis
voices I realized oh they were threading
a needle they needed to be more clear
for a STONER like me I didn't pick that
up till third feeling right and so like
the very end of it like she's gonna ask
a by Palpatine and she's like lying on
prostrate on the ground mm-hmm and then
she connects with them yeah and she
hears all the voices I want to see the
[ __ ] Jedi class trip picture show me
all of those [ __ ] Jedi like show me
the light like there's a great sequence
in in last Jedi where she's looking in
the mirror and she sees a thousand rays
going back and forth yeah show me those
[ __ ] Jedi show me oh my god show me
his Sokka show me show me every did you
hear like as soon as I heard her voice I
was like my [ __ ] tier I was like but
I knew to look for cuz he had done an
interview where he's like if you're in a
Sokka fan keep here he's pay attention
he didn't say what it was and then when
she started hearing the voices I was
like no no and he heard her voice and I
was like it's [ __ ] Canon I got so
[ __ ] happy like show me all of that
stuff and then the right of the front of
the [ __ ] line was it everybody was it
definitely had qui-gon they definitely
had a young Ben Kenobi and I think they
had a little old mix him in there as
well I'm in there who else mace windu
Yoda of course was as we're in there
yeah for sure yeah though I saw his name
in the credits
well like see how can you [ __ ] not
like that dude because that's fanservice
that the highest order show them to me I
know I'm Way just hearing that I'm like
cool no [ __ ] show me and have the
last person in that line right up to
Reyes she's lying on the ground is young
[ __ ] Princess Leia as she was
kneeling in front of the [ __ ] r2
putting the thing in saying you can do
this ray you just like give it to me
it's right there
it's like you walked right up to that
and was like I don't want open that door
because it's too [ __ ] cool behind
that door somebody just give you a bunch
of voices these too many fields behind
that door
Oh God I didn't realized man boy I was
[ __ ] satisfied with the audio major
cause I'm a podcast guy okay I'm happy
to hear everybody's voice but [ __ ]
you're right they really should have
showed us that [ __ ] I mean you get
everybody you get the [ __ ] overlook
picture about Jack Nicholson surrounded
by all these faces like you got this ray
you can do it and then do some cool
[ __ ] for [ __ ] I'm a little that
really how you think of it as the
Overlook picture in the shining yeah
that's your go-to analogy isn't it more
like the end of labyrinth where they're
like by Ludo spawn and they all pop out
and they're all good boy and I'll [ __ ]
say goodbye well the more direct lift is
Avatar The Last Airbender there's an
entire sequence where the avatar aang
has lost connection to the rest of the
avatars had he spent an entire season
kind of trying to reconnect with his
other like progenitor z-- and it's a
thousand generations of avatars and
there is that sequence when he finally
breaks through and there's everybody
like everybody and it hammers it [ __ ]
home that like oh you've reconnected
we're all here for you
go do the thing gray I mean and they've
done like what's the most amount of
force ghosts they've done at one time
like three six three I think right so
you could have and they don't even need
to be in the same place at the same time
you can say it up you know stop backseat
driving this movie again but that would
have been a cool idea you know and I and
I and I wanted like there's a there's a
video game I can't remember the name of
I remember its it follows star killer
played by Sam Witwer night wasn't a
night game before Force Unleashed Force
Unleashed where there's the climactic
sequence where that character has to
pull a Star Destroyer out of the sky
right and it's like the biggest [ __ ]
thing you've ever seen and like show me
that show me that Rey is the the like
apotheosis of Jedi show me that she's
more powerful than anybody who came
before them and armed with the power of
everybody who came before her have her
she did she [ __ ] killed Palpatine
yeah but [ __ ] like lightsabers thrown
alight I've seen the lightening
lightsaber [ __ ] before why doesn't she
save the fleet like why isn't she
[ __ ] like crashing starter stories
into each other
why isn't she moving mountains literally
with her [ __ ] mind because she's the
best that has ever been I actually would
like to see that man if she was just
[ __ ] unleashed and she started
bashing chips into one another and sure
there was a lot of ships they built who
who was gonna man these shits how did
they find like 3040 thousand commanders
this is like here's yo fleet he's like
you got a bunch of people qualified to
fly these [ __ ] things otherwise we
got a bunch of empty ships he's achieved
and battle it was very uh yeah I like
the idea that technology is getting
smaller and smaller and that they're
like we don't need a Death Star cuz now
every Star Destroyer is a Death Star
which followed last Jedi had that
[ __ ] cannon that was like this is
like a mini start [ __ ] a Death Star
of cannon maturity grant to did you I
did I mean he's really doing him
anything to do
he was just like good and I'm not
fighting you but it certainly what do
you mean good and evil well he's good oh
good and evil good and evil
yeah I'm just when you hire a Richard
grant I'm like where you get some [ __ ]
and I'm like oh they just let him be in
it he was fine but I just thought I
didn't know and what you met with you
like I [ __ ] dug it I was like maybe I
fell asleep
it was just a little it was another it
was another speed that I think again
it's calling back to [ __ ] a new hope
we just have a bunch of British to eat
oral evil that's all I was like he's a
good evil British dude yeah I thought he
was gonna be the spy at first like they
even give him that shot where like he's
by himself and the light is across his
eyes he's like who he's up to no good
he's actually got to no good because
he's just evil yeah I think we're meant
to think that could be the spy cuz he's
the new guide [ __ ] all those funny moon
Hawks it's like I'm the spy
almost like the whole honey's goes what
the [ __ ] is going to be recognized I did
it one of my favorite lines in the movie
was like right up front with her playing
chess with Chewie and they're like he
cheats and he gets all shitty their
corner and they're like of course you're
[ __ ] me goes you're 250 years old of
course you're better than us I [ __ ]
love that made me laugh it's just
[ __ ] funny enough and [ __ ] in the
Star Wars movie
what else did I absolutely love I loved
saying did you see wicket had a kid
wicket the Ewok had his own [ __ ]
wicked Junior [ __ ] and they just like he
was like I saw this [ __ ] 30 years ago
and [ __ ] they just keep killing this
Empire man I guess they didn't need our
help this time well they even let the
Ewoks comeback the only one didn't come
back though his [ __ ] Jar Jar man when
the Ewoks make it back in charge I don't
make it back that's [ __ ] strange but
yes I thought that wasn't a nice little
fanservice not I thought seeing the
Chewie getting the award was [ __ ]
nice wedge in the battle seeing him pop
up was nice you know look that [ __ ]
lightsabers fight between the two I'm
out of [ __ ] they shot that like where it
looks like they're fighting on top of
something with water hitting him a [ __ ]
I mean I know we're we're in a business
where they made Thanos and [ __ ] but I
was just looking at that going what part
of that's real and what part of it's not
it's fairly seamless you know froggen
was with the the mask thing man like
[ __ ] first he's got it in a cool
collector kit like when he opens it up
and [ __ ] like when you open up your
sideshow collectible and then later on
he puts it on a [ __ ] collectible
stand and shed well they masturbate to
if it's not in the
Electrical thing - this is always and
leans against the pole
one day what'd you think of his arc it's
three movies about his arc you know from
I had to good I dug it I I wasn't like I
said I wasn't that much of a fan of him
kind of regressing - I need a boss and
then I'm gonna kill that boss but
actually now the boss is gonna offer me
something cool so that's cool I need a
super evil boss so I don't feel that bad
about being evil I wanted his that you
were in the writers room
I want his redemption to be a little
look I'm I'm I wanted it to be bigger
than Vader's to a certain degree because
it's the same sort of thing right like
Vader turns kills the Emperor like and
many dies and like nobody but Luke knows
that his father had turned back got
Anakin Skywalker back like and the mayor
nobody knows the turn I know what I
wanted them to Oh like I I wanted I
wanted the person who gets on [ __ ]
Poe's headset and says I got everybody
to be kylo Ren I wanted that to be Ben
solo because he disappears from the drum
once he leaves like talking to his dad
and he's gone until he's like I'm gonna
run back to this shitty planet and I'm
gonna fight that makes a friend who
nobody cares about but whatever and then
the stance I decide by this girl and
fight more people which I didn't last
movie so whatever he's like I had to
stop at a mall went to chess King but
this [ __ ] nice sweater and [ __ ] not
as nice as Chris Evans and knives Alba
[ __ ] him man so here we go let's do this
that was so funny man like suddenly he's
in hose or his good boy clothes still
Sunday church clothes yes nice knit I'm
done rebelling I'm done we're Maemo
blacks mom it was like when my kid put
away her black clothing she was like now
I'm wearing bright clothing I was like
all he grew up but if but if Ben solo
brings the rescue fleet Ben solo was
that because who the hell need like
Lando so you go talk to everybody I'm
gonna go talk to everybody and then it
talks to everybody it's all off-screen
it's all who gives a [ __ ]
but if Ben solo shows up shows that he's
been redeemed by bringing the fleet that
rescues the rebellion yeah like if
anybody has to wrestle with like and
it's better than like hey showed up to
saber you know at the end which is kind
of what did he does you don't though
because the emperor beats them both but
she doesn't need his help she doesn't
she's [ __ ] the most powerful [ __ ]
jealous reconnect with the Jedi and now
she does [ __ ] like he's ornamental and
that scene so you give him something to
do you give the characters around him
somebody to respond to its [ __ ] that
guy that guy saved our asses right like
and the amazing they didn't get the
information that he turned they're like
blast them out of the sky [ __ ] it
ends tragically I bought you all these
ships and pop like chicken sandwiches
how could you kill me we don't want to
the drive through this way it took us so
long yeah I could see you're right in
your theory of like like Lando being the
guy that brings the fleet I'm like right
the [ __ ] on because he [ __ ] saved the
day and Jedi and you're like and that's
the problem is that they're still
telling you the old story as opposed to
the new story which would be like kylo
figured this [ __ ] out he's the hero on
stuff you could also have him kick Lando
out of the pilot's seat of the money and
Falcon and have him sit next to
Chewbacca they could [ __ ] all be
there he's better knew yeah although I
would have to think that Chewie
wood-pulp that motherfucker's head if he
tries to do that I know somebody better
let you we know that he rip his [ __ ]
arms off dudes like oh my god it's true
[Laughter]
Rey could force heal them back well he
[ __ ] the Emperor grew his fingers
back like they kept showing his bony
broken ass fingers because they are a
diet of the thoughts oh yeah he was like
now I'll take both your power and juice
up and [ __ ] but they didn't turn into
husks or anything he just took a bunch
of force out and they just passed out
and stuff I'm what do you think about
him living through the destruction of
Death Star like I saw that [ __ ] it was
vaporized I didn't see no big chunk
falling down the end or anything like
that I think it does a little bit of
disservice in a weird way for a movie
that feels so much about fanservice it
does the ultimate fan disservice by
rendering Anakin Skywalker's sacrifice
null and void oh my god I knew you would
have a hot take on it and I knew one
person would applaud it you're right
to me what do you mean explain because
Anakin Skywalker like once Darth Vader
is sort of redeemed by his son yes kills
the [ __ ] Emperor like this was this
was this the signal of my being over and
done with Allah said I will kill myself
to kill that dude and save my son and
all the people that he loves including
you know the other daughter who I don't
talk to that much and so by like oh I
didn't die it's like what the dude
killed you like he killed himself to
kill you yeah [ __ ] it
you're back I'm back I don't know I'm
only mostly dead yeah I'll go with it at
first I was like how do you lived
through that but you know what we did
see Leia to the Kari Poppins through
midair after she got blown out the sky
in the last movie so there's precedent
maybe that's what he did he just floated
I mean it's all [ __ ] space magic so
anything is possible
beyond what he's a clone which you also
then get the Hobbit goes right off the
bat he's like well clones
moving on wait what Dominic in the movie
when they're like Palpatine's back he's
like yeah cloning he literally says
something along the lines of yeah Club
Hobbit [ __ ] yeah right at the beginning
and then that you just go what did you
get that nope I mean you see a bunch of
snow peas like I made I saw yeah yeah I
think the illusion is cloning technology
and then Dominic kind of like says
references cloning in relation to
Palpatine so what is the idea the ideas
he put his consciousness in a new body
yeah like he why if you were gonna grow
new body why the [ __ ] would you use that
party it's all busted and [ __ ] it's
got no legs half fingers and [ __ ] I'd be
like can I get a new model well it I
think like for people who've done the EU
that was this EU story that the Emperor
cloned himself and thus kind of lives
forever so he had always had like a
closet full of clones so just waiting
God yeah waiting like up and they're all
busted and broken like he is so much so
that he's like I need to suck your force
juice
and it's like 30 years laya I didn't get
that I got the distinct impression that
we're meant to believe that that is the
[ __ ] Emperor who was standing on the
Return of the Jedi Death Star otherwise
why would a clone be [ __ ] busted up
and ruined man as a broke-ass clone gee
I guess what is it snow okay snow yeah I
kind of took it as Snoke was like a
failed version like he's trying to get
himself right is that what you got out
of that did you get that like your Star
Wars man you could just that's that's
dark empire comic book right from 20
years ago I really thought I know this
is a probably I should let it go because
it's a movie about [ __ ] magic in
space but like he can't be a clone with
busted fingers like who the [ __ ] what
kind of badass terrible clone is that I
mean I would have taken Snoke body he
looked pretty [ __ ] good you know
that's living all of the clone bodies
were kept on the Death Star
and so most of them [ __ ] died and
that's the only one that survived the
fire I like his Star Wars movie maybe
but then like how do you also get like a
billion SIF in that [ __ ] like SIF
concert yeah the [ __ ] was that about
like we've all just been hanging out I
like just somebody had to build the
ships and [ __ ] but like holy [ __ ] I'm
like they [ __ ] the first order there's
the army right there man all these dudes
and hoods and [ __ ] this [ __ ] pit of
doom we're gonna stand around and have
an eyes wide shut orgy [ __ ] in
a Star Wars movie what is it they were
there spirits of the Sith there were
spirits god damn it what am I missing
like did they say that in the movie were
they but if they were killed by falling
rocks in the end because they were
running
it wasn't real why would you run makes
as much sense as giving a clone busted
fingers man like I don't know I thought
they were supposed to be real in there
where did you get the ghost thing that's
what I guys they were part of the SIF
cult-like Thuggee cult they were always
there though from the moment you see him
they don't show you the other side of
the room and then suddenly they do and
they're all [ __ ] there do you get
that I think there's a scene you want to
have in that movie that isn't in that
movie yeah I was just like four times in
the first time I didn't catch where they
came from but the second time I was
really looking and I saw like oh they're
all there there been them waiting and
[ __ ] they're just real quiet they like
let him do his speech all right now uh
he's talking Shh I'm sober as [ __ ] and
that didn't make any sense to me at all
that's what is the only way I was cool
with all those people as I was like well
they must have built all the starters
tours cuz then again you know maybe it's
meant to be him and he's just like
imagine again that's like five thousand
dudes like at a shipyard like how long
does it take 5,000 people to build
10,000 Star Destroyers oh my god this is
like you know could God make a boulder
big enough that he can't lift it over
his head kind of question I can't answer
that 3d printing 3d printing yeah I
always just took that that you know the
em the whole Imperial fleet wasn't on
Endor at the end of Return of the Jedi
the Emperor has got his private garage
that's I just figured that me too
private garage Star Destroyers yeah but
just like Jay Leno
who's [ __ ] kill him either he's also
a clone I believe yeah you know I too
was never like boy they beat everybody
in that one movie like you know that
ships elsewhere and [ __ ] but without you
know the Emperor and without a Darth
Vader it's not like anyone else wants to
take over so if you kill the figurehead
and you figure it's all over yeah I mean
it's like looking for those law
I used to work in a space magic movie is
like whatever like a they have space
magic be like it's the time travel an
end game like it doesn't make any sense
it doesn't hold together it does what
the movie needs it to do because of
space magic so fine whatever but I just
like who who is this guy why is he if
he's a clone that's weird now we're
actually bringing science into the space
magic
why isn't he just a dude who hasn't died
before like you thought you saw me die I
didn't I'm in a scooby-doo mystery and
I'm back they needed to keep [ __ ] baby
Yoda simple please could have just been
two hours of return rise of Skywalker
and everyone felt like it's amazing he
just keeps eating soup that little
[ __ ] man let's we talked about a bunch
let's open it up to the audience now
everyone who talks about what you're not
we're not doing QA I can't answer for
this movie and really neither can Marc
apparently so just we want to hear what
you guys think you heard us talk about
the movie so give us your review and
tell us like the [ __ ] you liked if you
want to improve it feel free and stuff
we got nine things to give away ten oh
[ __ ] we got a bunch of games alright
yeah no we got a bunch of things to give
away all right so we'll start with a
figure of ten because we've got five
sets of tickets from the good folks at
4dx and if you're looking to watch a
movie in 40x which I can't tell you
enough you have to do before you leave
this world man [ __ ] see all the
modern wonders of the ancient world and
[ __ ] go see a 40 X movie it's a great
presentation I imagine with this movie
well since the crawl happens the seat
will lean back and [ __ ] and then you'll
fly around it's gonna be a good time so
if you win these tickets you can get to
go see a 40 X movie I'm gonna be soaking
wet on that like lightsaber battle scene
yeah yeah water everywhere and other
reasons I don't know depending and if
you don't win that you might win a Jay
and Silent Bob smell my finger game
from the good folks at play storm that's
right smell my finger man my mom is
incredibly proud and if not you'll win
another game Jay and Silent Bob's big
fat card on game also from the good
folks at play storm man all right so
what's your name young camper my name is
Sebastian everyone give it up for
Sebastian Sebastian the floor is yours
this is a safe place a safe space feel
free to tell us what you thought about
the rise of Skywalker okay so the
biggest thing I think I mean if anyone
wants to agree with but I always wanted
to see somebody building their
lightsaber and we get the very end of
Rey showing her gold lightsaber which
hopefully was a double-bladed lightsaber
everybody like why could we have just
not seen that so wait that lightsaber
that she had that was the whole death
it's made of her staff yeah it looked
like it I've watched the movie like I
said four times at one point I was like
that meant to be like did she have
Palpatine's [ __ ] lightsaber cuz it
turned in a different way but I guess
it's it made out of her staff
it was made out of her staff which makes
sense I mean yeah that's three movies
which means it might have to be
double-sided like Darth Maul which means
maybe she is after all what are the gold
lightsabers signify right isn't there
different classes there's like Jedi
Knight what is it
senticles yeah okay they're like the
Warriors of the Jedi cool so it would
have just made sense to just see one
quick scene of just Hurley's putting
that together and building her badass
gold lightsaber so you would have liked
to have seen that but what did you think
of the movie itself oh the movie was
exactly how you guys said it like it
just it it hit everything close to home
like for me it was as to my closest
recollection was the first movie I've
ever seen and for Star Wars a new hope
and it just seeing that finally together
made it and even with everything we had
to say like I agree with everything that
can be said about it it still was worth
seeing
it was a it was a good nice sweet tie to
the end of the saga I agree I believe
they tied it up like look they tied it
up better than I ever could that was
what i sat there going like I [ __ ]
would have thought of that I wouldn't
have thought of that and so but yeah I
thought they tied up what is you and so
that's your review thumbs up thumbs down
I give it a thumbs up with a little bit
of maybe tilt towards the middle and
stuff like that but I it makes sense
like if there was so much that they had
to do within one movie I mean yeah sure
have been great to see in episode 10 but
like it's it makes sense right let's
take an episode [ __ ] ten makes it you
can that is a [ __ ] winning question
or winning review not only do you get
the tickets you also get a bumper
sticker from Nate man Nate's bumper
sticker signed by me Marc well done
Kevin
alright who's going next who's got
something to say about this movie guys
get it off their chest which named Adam
proud him he's next
I enjoy the movie alright those people
that liked the last Jedi for the first
30 minutes of riots of Skywalker I was
like wow this is a really good Indian
Jones film where they're going to
different place and then the relics and
all that stuff the one thing I was a
little bit more disappointing was like
the Falcon like who gets to own the
Falcon at the end of the movie you see
Poe driving it you see Lando and I think
it ends up with Ray at the end that was
kind of the one thing also thing it does
it winds up with rice she takes it to
tattooing it lands like a few feet from
me yeah and now son one thing I was
really looking forward to him like oh I
wonder who gets to keep the Falcon now
that cop Chuy can keep its make him his
own pilot that don't captain give it to
[ __ ] Chewie yeah man like [ __ ]
he's like [ __ ] the metal give me the
ship like have him have his own crew or
something like that bites also I was
like at the end of Moya was like wow
they had a lot of like seating here like
he was his own like major thing for the
whole portion in the movie but I
thoroughly enjoyed it I I'm last Jedi as
one of my favorites personally yeah last
Jedi ages well I think some people still
hate it on
and stuff but it's got some cool shin
and again I'll always feel like and it's
not their fault dude Carrie Fisher
passed away after they made that movie
and stuff but I still think sticking her
in the chair would have been like oh it
makes that movie underneath us what was
his name oh hi Clark
Akbar that was my second like at least
give me AK for somebody I grew up with
and [ __ ] yeah so that I could really
care although that's it won't doesn't
take away from the fact that that's an
amazing scene and still one of the best
moments in like any Star Wars film
watching that thing go Lightspeed
through the [ __ ] started Shroff was
awesome
yeah thank you win man give it up for
him he got it thank you I went late all
right where we going next what's your
name steel steel give it up for steel
everybody I I sort of got the feeling it
was written based around not what people
loved about seeing in the sequel trilogy
but around what people would have loved
seeing in the sequel trilogy
it was sort of it was so it was really
focused on original trilogy but I've
just got a just the thing that really
sort of stopped my like really took me
out of it was the Palpatine reveal and
just what that changes about the first
two films and about the foot like the
last four years of Star Wars fandom was
how many people like the myth of Kevin
Smith now this is it'll it'll tie in is
like I'm sure you have got thousands of
stories of people coming up to you and
going oh I got into filmmaking cuz I
heard your story yes and you were just
in New Jersey and you just ran up your
credit cards and you came from nothing
and that gave me that belief that I
could do whatever I wanted to do as well
and I sort of got the feeling or not
feeling but know that a lot of people
were inspired by Ray for that same thing
and it kind of feels like that it comes
out later on or about heaven Smith
eliminates that Oh Kevin Smith's grandma
[ __ ] Harvey Weinstein and that wait
for after we made clerks it feels like
like where they like you know whether
you're a real personal raise a real
person I'll be honest with you did not
expect to hear his name tonight of all
nights but you made it work kind of
although my grandmother's in [ __ ]
spinning in her grave there's a lot of
spitting on graves this week the dead
speak but yeah I sort of feel like for
people that believed in that for for
years it was sort of taken away and as I
bring up your story because the wait for
four years you believed it on the first
movie - yeah I sort of I wouldn't you
didn't think they were setting it up for
like she gonna be related to somebody
[ __ ] Gordon I to be honest I didn't
think that'd be that hacky I thought
that like the first one was about like
weak skywalk was connected to that and
then this time the thing is like she
actually did come from nothing and and
save the galaxy so I'm just I'm just
wondering if that sort of reference to
your life and how your vinspired people
sort of changes your opinion of that
reveal it absolutely does put through
that prism I'm like oh [ __ ] yeah that
would be that would be weird
but again I'm I'm there for fanservice
so they say she's related to Palpatine
and I'm like oh he was in the other
movies alright you know rather than like
she's not related to anybody which i
think is a compelling idea and a brave
idea but like an idea that I still bump
into I'm like I gotta believe we took
the journey with this kid for a reason
like the first journey we took is with
Luke Skywalker and then they [ __ ]
told us about Luke's dad and [ __ ] how
Luke got there and stuff and it should
feel like this trilogy deals with the
effects of a Skywalker somewhere and
they kind of do and stuff so I guess you
know like Mark said they take care of
that with kylo Ren and I should have
been happy with that but like at the
same time I'm like yeah I wanted her to
be related to somebody but you guys are
really selling me on the idea of her
being a nobody like you're right I
hadn't thought about it like that
through my own personal prism and I
think that like thank you for making it
about me now I can understand that the
thing we all fell in love with the first
thing we often love with was a new hope
with Star Wars and in that movie Luke
Skywalker is just a [ __ ] kid from
nowhere from the furthest spot of any
place important in the galaxy and he
saves everybody and that myth that that
myth which is a little bit of an
American myth it's a little bit of a
immigrant myth to a certain degree that
you can come from nothing and be
something great is powerful it's also a
little bit of the the Harry Potter kind
of flips it is to a certain degree which
is yes you're the kid who lives under
the stairs but you actually come from
something great and they're both
attractive and they're both lovely and
wonderful but I think that there there
was room to have more of thee you're
just some [ __ ] kid and you know what
some [ __ ] kid can do amazing things
yes it's like a cynical view of it is
like especially in 2019 is you can
achieve anything if you're able to
someone important oh my god that is the
unspoken lesson yeah you don't want this
to be like the rise of nepotism
[Music]
which it really I gotta call my daughter
who's the star of my latest he'll be
related to somebody she better be but
you're right it is actually a far more
powerful idea and that's what Ryan was
doing wasn't he just going like you know
having [ __ ] kylo Ren be like you're
nobody
you have nothing to do with this [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] do you think you are and
you know her becoming that thing even
though she's not entitled to it yeah
that is a more compelling where the Ryan
ends that movie with someone [ __ ] a
stableboy kid like you know holding up a
room like it's a lightsaber yeah we all
can be something great it bugged me when
I saw it but now I actually kind of
think is I like that ending you know it
didn't give me the ending I wanted which
is like they're all sitting somewhere
and that's the thing that movie did not
deliver on expectation because of the is
surprising at every turn force awakens
is surprising because it's back who knew
holy [ __ ] you could do this he's back
this is [ __ ] great and then the last
Jedi was like now this is what you could
do the Star Wars movie you could break
it and do weird [ __ ] and if I can do
this and guess what this doesn't mean
this anymore and then this one feels
like it just like well it gave us some
new [ __ ] where it's like now you can
because of the force you can hand
somebody something across a galaxy which
I guess plays into I don't know it
doesn't plan to him get given her the
dice but those dice disappeared okay who
what do you mean what in this movie but
I mean in last Jedi Luke gives Leia the
the dice yeah and then he disappeared it
was Lear later on so they weren't really
which also to your point before about
the hold or remove if they change that
out then would all be sort of like going
did you know they had a scene with Luke
Skywalker and Princess Leia and they
edit it out of the film John I mean so
that's why I was always like you've got
to keep it going because I want to see
Carrie and Mark that's a good point as
good point if she dies in that ship then
you don't get
that seamless I - how you man you get it
earlier where she's like I'm the ship
and he's like don't do this and he's
there's your scene yeah right I'm making
a better one now a great Star Wars movie
they see how it takes a [ __ ] village
man yeah feels like on this they could
have done one more like everybody sit in
the room and let's talk about this and
come up with cool [ __ ] yeah I don't
know on this one it sort of feels like
it took a message board yeah it just
seems like a real they honestly feel
like they checked a lot like boxes made
sure like they tried to make everybody
to mock sing about what he wanted was
something that you always wanted that
you didn't know
yeah and that's Adam like I was shocked
Adam driver being Ben solo like he's
such a good actor the way he changed and
like lucasfilm's tried to give us a new
looks
I mean a new Han Solo many times from -
render - Han Solo to Poe Dameron but the
way he became young Harrison Ford with
the book and just that that shrug where
he gets the lifesavers like I didn't
know I wanted that but I was like that
was he was amazing he's he's like I
thought was this great but he's like too
good an actor for Star Wars and we're
lucky to have him he was bright star
wars' is filled with actors who were
little do good for Star Wars
yeah he's [ __ ] great in that [ __ ]
movie man that's a JJ brought him to the
party that's a JJ fine I mean he must
have seen him on girl I thought that was
actually a Kathleen Kennedy she brought
him in yeah because she was like a big
girls fan where'd she see him
somebody told me later on the Gen Euston
who cast cop out like we were talking
about something and I was like [ __ ]
goddamn it that Adam driver kids amazing
she's like he came in on cop-out and I
was like well he dodged a [ __ ] bullet
down he's got a huge career now yeah
Kathleen like like like eyed him for it
and JJ sold him on it with the arc of
kylo Ren so I think there's like like he
she sort of chose him and then JJ like
gave him
the peach that one emo how to do it he
was like it'll be cool I swear at one
point you're gonna [ __ ] mellow out
and we're [ __ ] casual clothing but
until then emo all the way man you're
gonna got the [ __ ] you'll get to kiss
this hot unknown girl from England it's
gonna be the best once that it was they
brought back the Knights of Ren just for
like a boy band shot like they were wide
open
it looked like Creed for a second they
were just standing on the clip and they
were bugging circle in the mansion there
were offers like this another nights are
those the other students who left Luke's
Academy know they know or not know they
are just some bad boys he's collected
that's his gang yeah I think there's a
comic where Luke and although the comics
of like these comments already
contradicted by the movie but there's a
comment came out this week that Luke and
kylo come across them on a mission and
there's I think a seventh ninth Ren
night Thorin night of Ren that is not in
the film so I guess at the end of the
comics he gets like and kylo Ren takes
over but yeah he was around before the
whole that the Knights of Ren would be
around before him yeah yeah and then you
join their club and then he eventually
kills them all here and the call he ran
the club here and then closed the club
rather dramatically but it's sort of
we'd like I felt like the movie was
ingénue view of those guys and you're
like we were [ __ ] boys why you killed
where's your [ __ ] black ear where's
your mask wear that sweater come don't
[ __ ] it up holy boy I felt like the film
was like listening to a podcast in 1.5
and then skipping forward a minute every
five minutes and I felt like there was a
lot of like interesting things because
you're talking about the star at the
montage it was like another ten minutes
before that where kylo and went to an
Oracle that sort of explained to him
what to do what yeah how do you know
this because I I'm at the can't like
this is where people I speak are so
where there was four
that did go away yeah yeah yeah come
buddy was like this boring man get right
to the [ __ ] where he starts killing
people I don't know it seems like they
like wanted to cut it down when they
should have just like gone made it be
avenged yeah let it be three hours son
felt it was longer than endgame was oh
is that right yeah he was like that felt
long I was like it's two hours in 27
minutes I think it felt long maybe with
the right information added it wouldn't
have felt as long like if they expanded
some [ __ ] explained some [ __ ] all right
you win man do you want tickets or a
game
I'll take tickets tickets they are
[ __ ] thank you
I'll give him up he won man your stroke
theories your Snoke theory sucked that's
awesome you don't want your stroke
theories your son no no and it's done in
the Kenner font man that makes me so
happy that's the blue font of a happy
childhood right there okay what do we
got JC hey man hi what's your name first
of all steel wars everybody I really
like the film you know about you're
going to advance me what is it key key
yes key give it up for key everybody
keys here
now go I like the film even though I had
a lot of issues with it one of the
reasons why I liked it I think is
because I had I had low expectations due
to last Jedi I am a last night apologist
I would tell people it'll still go watch
it and watch it again because there was
still a lot of really good things in it
some in last Jedi corrupt yeah so many
things that we even disagreed with I
think that made it better but there were
still quite a few issues and so again
that's one of the reasons why I was able
to like this film even more with that
said I still felt like this movie had
too many Marvel hands on it who
explained when Poe is giving that
Captain America speech right I
it took me out of the movie it was no
longer Star Wars I wasn't watching a
Star Wars movie why I wasn't out but it
be fair long before Captain America
been doing speeches and movies to rally
people and [ __ ] no I I agree but not
installers right can you name the stores
on that that did that
now generally it's just like here's how
you blow up a [ __ ] thing in front of
the screen they're showing you like the
math like this is how we're gonna do it
and in this one it was just like Marvel
they were they were doing the montage as
he were speaking so to me that was a
Marvel to be fair rope one has a pretty
good speech that is very true yeah
except that they took out the whole
cross so it's not part of the the nine
at this point even though I love that
one more than the last two or three yeah
so I felt like it was very much washed
in Marvel hands also I have to point it
out I thought it was hilarious to see
caller end doing the the Michael Jackson
moonwalk at the very beginning of the
scene of the movie killing people I was
like Barry Allen intuitive very much
though backwards he did yeah man it was
wait what was your first issue what was
the first thing you brought up colleges
for last gen I apologize for last night
no it's not that it's unrelated
unrelated I'm a I'm a apologist for the
movie like I still liked it I didn't
don't mama nobody's got to apologize for
this [ __ ] either people like it or they
don't like it and stuff is that simple
movies are subjective it's that simple
but that being said what I did one thing
I was okay with Palpatine being alive
was because the Sith are always about
like we want to cheat death power is in
living forever even you know not [ __ ]
understanding that the body [ __ ] rots
so like that's why the emperor looks the
way it does like you can live forever
but you're eventually just gonna be like
[ __ ] Haase command [ __ ] like that Jed
I understood that like the true power
lies in what's beyond that's staying
connected to this corporal world you
will never know the true power
Ben Kenobi says if you strike me down I
become more powerful than you could
possibly imagine because the SIF can
only imagine like extending this life
that's why [ __ ] I'll hang out in
the cave with busted fingers because
it's like at least I'm alive man
everyone else I know is [ __ ] dead
you'd [ __ ] oh that I get to live forever
because they pass over into that next
place and then they [ __ ] force ghost
it up for the rest of their lives what
were you saying I thought he reminded me
of mojo
Oh Joe marble mojo Oh [ __ ] who-who did
Palpatine behind here mojo yeah he's got
no legs he's just kind of floating
around and [ __ ] like that
well they got him hooked up to a you
know you have been chosen crane and [ __ ]
that was great question what do you want
game or tickets tickets well-done pick
those tickets man come get them give it
up for him
[Applause]
alright what's your name young lady hi
I'm Abbie Abbie give it up for Abbey
she's next I just wanted to go back to
what you said about the end of the movie
when all of these spaceships from
everywhere came in I think the important
distinction is that they didn't know
them because one of the things that the
enemy does and this is sort of repeated
and other things like Harry Potter is
that they try to make you feel like
you're alone and the important
distinction is that you're not alone
there are people out there that are
going through the same thing and and
want to strive to be where you know beat
the enemy and you're not alone and I
think that's the point of it I also feel
like it kind of sheds a light or a
mirror on our society all good sci-fi
does that so it kind of reflects our
State of the Union right now and how
we're so divided and it actually says
hey you're not alone you're not the only
one that feels this way you're not it's
not just all bad if there are good
people out there and if we you know come
together we can beat the enemy and I
think that's the important distinction
of that I got that too
[Applause]
no I totally I agree with that sentiment
I still think you could have put a face
on that that that would have been more
emotional for us as an audience like the
sheer magnitude of it is cool
but then you need that emotional crux at
the middle of it and and Lando doesn't
do that for those characters so but yes
absolutely there's gonna be a [ __ ]
rescue cavalry that shows up I just
wanted like our characters to give a
[ __ ] about who that was who showed up
and I and I think it also felt like a
Ryan correction scene as well cuz like
in last Jedi they're like we called for
everybody
nobody's coming and you're like Jesus
Christ this rebellion is small but in
this movie they're like everybody's here
and I think that that to your point I
think there's there's also a way for
this movie or even Star Wars in general
to to focus a little bit on that
unification right like so much of this
has always been about there's a dark
side of the force on the light side of
the force and you can choose to follow
one side or the other of the duck said
it's more powerful the light side is
more pure whatever that is but in Rey
you could have had this character who's
like I am a Palpatine and I'm also a
Jedi and I am all of it like the dark
side the light side all of that is
[ __ ] the forces the force is the
force you do with it what you're going
to do with it be a good person do good
things like and I think there's a way to
unify in that sentiment but like just
because you're born one thing maybe I'm
a Palpatine maybe you're [ __ ] farmer
from nowhere maybe you're a little kid
who's working the stables you can all be
great and I think that was you know if
you're going to be fee Matic about it
that was a slightly missed opportunity I
agree with that I I think they could
definitely have done more with like
showing all shades of being a Jedi and
what that means and it's about your
choices not just your power right you
had a smart statement it created another
smart statement you wind [ __ ] you want
tickets or a game
tickets there you go may I give it up
for she one who we got next
what's your name captain David David oh
we got left her games David so first of
all I gave it a 8.5 I think the reason
it was so high is because I saw at 40 X
well let's talk about that David I think
my favorite part was when weird when
they were in kind of ship the Falcon
came up and blew everyone back and when
that happened although yeah work
everyone [ __ ] goes and then kylo does
this [ __ ] which other it was metal so
what happened all the fans kicked in and
the sea started going back I was like
holy [ __ ] Kevin wasn't [ __ ] around
when he said did you go backwards for
the cross yeah
and then what else did what was the
other standout what about like he said
when they were fighting on the on the
thing was there a lot of water spitting
in your face yeah there was did they
really
nope oh my god man like you're getting a
facial
[Music]
that's alright so like that's a good
review go see it in 40x yeah absolutely
alright somebody give it an 8.5 do you
have other things to say about out of 10
out of 10 yeah
I do have problems with it and one of my
biggest problems was when that Jedi's
when you hear that Jedi voices there's
this voice that idea I kind of
recognized he said bring balance to the
force like I did yeah that looked at
that it was Anakin I was like [ __ ] you
like you did ballad [ __ ] you whiny
little [ __ ] yeah did he bring bounce he
was the one that was supposed to bring
balance to the force he did well Hills
the upper that's that's the end of his
story and then the end and did that and
they ended that so he's like bring
balance and force like I did and she's
like amber is alive he's like oh [ __ ]
well what was my whole story arc [ __ ]
I'll go sit over there there's sand in
places I don't like it's so
uncomfortable do you think so wait that
was do you think they got Hayden
Christensen they did yeah he's in
credits did they get Jake Lloyd no I
think they went with Hayden and but they
also laser-sharp Star Wars burned from
the crowd somebody said I think Jake I
think the cops got Jake Lloyd very funny
that's right very mean very funny all
right is that all you got
you don't need or I got one more okay
good about the Ben and Leia situation
that you guys were talking about earlier
yeah yeah I don't know if it's because
at the place I am in my life right now
that my grandmother passed away just a
month ago I'm sorry to hear that but I
feel like when she reached out to Ben
Ben the whole movie was like I can't go
back I already [ __ ] up I went I did so
much bad [ __ ] I can't go back to my mom
right he even says that out loud he's
like you can't go back to her I can't
just like I can yeah I feel like he
believed that that wasn't kind of true
but as soon as he felt that she's gone
he really couldn't go back anymore so
it's the way what would that mean that
would mean that she connected herself to
him yes I don't refer him to realize
that it was like a last call like if
like if your mom decided to call you
like right before she passes away and if
you're like bickering with your siblings
you would stop completely correct right
so I feel like that's what he felt and
then her connecting himself to him it
was like telling Ben saying that it's
not too late I still feel like you can
come back whenever you want
fuckin'-a that's beautiful well done
that is such a beautiful response it's a
shame to offer you to smell my finger
game but we got a big fat card on game
or the smell my finger game which one do
you want smell my fingers there you go
man give it up for an excellent job
excellent bucket job did they did
somebody miss their 40 X ticket we got
our spare 40 X check whoever won your 40
actually left one behind you've got one
[ __ ] goes to have to you only got one
main time yeah if it's you come on we
can pass it over to you
what's your name yeah my name is Kevin
yeah how are you good seeing you again
sir yeah that's good seeing you I
enjoyed the movie yeah I did have a few
Kevin busts out his list he's like I had
a few thoughts it's no it's not bad but
I thought Babu Freck was the baby Yoda
of the movie
rick has not gotten any attention here
yet or any love the Babu Frick I saw
that scene getting shot when he turned
you know [ __ ] blows out c-3po and
c3po goes down so I saw them and that
voice they were doing like on the set
sound exactly like I'm sure they
rerecorded and [ __ ] but whoever was
operating Babu Frick was also going like
well the Babu freakin [ __ ] the same
stuff so when I saw the movie I was like
surely they'll replace that but they did
no that's [ __ ] cute well yeah Babu
free keys hey and all that [ __ ] was kind
of fun and then I was surprised that
they promoted Finn and Poe when Lando is
just chilling there been the general for
like 20 years
yeah yeah clearly it does not require
much to get a promotion to general in
the Rebel Alliance like [ __ ] Han Solo
was it general and like you did one
thing once you're a general you're a
general you're a general everyone look
under your seat
it's like about like a lieutenant maybe
like a major that's like a half step
before I'm running [ __ ] nope
they got rebel soldiers and nothing but
generous top-heavy in this army aren't
we and then when Ray could feel kylo on
the ship and chewy on the ship and then
they have their battle and he's trying
to figure out where she is
I don't like she's holding the
specialist if knife in your room but she
doesn't you know he doesn't realize that
until his grandfather's mast falls on
the floor yeah there's there's weird
[ __ ] where like he can reach through and
grab a necklace from her and then take
it and then he's tracing her across the
galaxy because I was new oh okay but I
like that the celebration was 42 years
as well as oh they said that's kind of
sweet oh I was just lost in like oh no
there's another one of those matrix
parties remember that oh my god like a
Jeff Goldblum jam like it's the Grand
Master just like it's called a yes who
did
lin-manuel Miranda did the music for
that celebration scene mm-hmm no wonder
I wanted to rise up I'm an softballs
all day we were all in the room where
that happened but you got to be on
screen for something I did actually get
to be in it if you I mean I'm a walk-on
technically a welcome when Poe is on
Kouji me and he's they're doing that
nice tracking shot where he sees like
the first order stormtroopers knocking
on doors and [ __ ] harassing people
and [ __ ] as he crosses the toward you
know the gang to tell him like [ __ ]
they're everywhere he passes like a dude
walking and a robot walking and I'm the
dude walking next to the robot and then
when they go yeah I could sweet
so you're silent Bob in the star war any
much yeah which is what JJ said on the
day he's just like you I was like who's
the dude he goes he's your J no I was
like huh
so yeah I'm a you know a little kid who
has always loved Star Wars and [ __ ] and
did a voice and force awakens I got to
actually be in it like when I watch the
movie I'm like oh [ __ ] there's me and
stuff
I've got no lines in this one no no no
just like Mark and reboot yeah familiar
with it he's got less lines in Silent
Bob that's true
yeah but I got to be in it was very very
cool the day I shot if you look deep in
the background chip kid is being
harassed by a stormtrooper and the
stormtrooper is Jamie Oliver Ed Sheeran
was there that day he was another
stormtrooper and [ __ ] like is just JJ's
kind of brilliant cuz like he everyone
he meets he's like hey man come be in
Star Wars because they've got so many
[ __ ] extras so people show up and
he's like put on a stormtrooper costume
and boom they're in the [ __ ] movie
and also you don't have to pay that many
extras if you should get bunch of famous
people buying stormtroopers not true by
the way I think I did get a pair I think
I actually got paid I think they had to
pay me yeah I think I finally made some
money off Star Wars man after giving
them my money all this time and [ __ ] I
think they sent me a little scratch is
it me or does stormtrooper armor
actually get you killed faster than if
you were just naked yeah like just balls
out running around like you might have a
shot of not getting killed
truly well that armor does nothing like
shot in the chest where it's supposed to
be the strongest and just holds what's
the point
no shot the Army's fine everybody else
just goes down yeah that's true the
generals are safe I guess there's still
many of them anymore no wonderful [ __ ]
you win a game yeah I've come to judge
game
take a card out game big scene all right
where we're going next JC who was your
name's Susana everyone give it up for
Susana I'm good how you doing good yeah
so I mean I agree with you it wasn't
like the most amazing movie in the world
probably not the most amazing Star Wars
movie in the world but I [ __ ] loved
it I thought it was so fun it was such
awesome fan service and good action and
Chewie got a medal and she we broke down
and I broke down and a lot of awesome
things there are wonderful flourishes
that made it worth the [ __ ] journey
and I don't get to feel that way very
often in a movie theater and yes like
did they do it as well as endgame like
you know that's it doesn't matter as
long as you feel well
the short answer is no but like but I
felt like good enough like thanks [ __ ]
that rocks in its own unique way and
stuff like I got exactly what I wanted
what I paid for and I felt good about it
you know well no I agree I feel like the
little kid in me who watched these
flicks with my pops was just so [ __ ]
happy like it was so satisfying but
talking about unexpected things that I
wouldn't have seen coming and that
really resonated with me I thought one
of the most emotionally powerful scenes
was the conversation between the two
child soldiers talking about how they
didn't know who they were they had been
stolen they were brought up in this
thing that they didn't believe in that
they were gonna get killed if they tried
to defect and I thought that was so
unexpected like talk about things I
didn't expect Star Wars to delve into
but are really resonant right now and
our thing that should be talked about I
I kind of in retrospect wanted a little
more of that and I just found sort of
like social commentary that would it was
really powerful I think that was that
was handled I mean I think you're right
like a little bit more would have been
nice but it was handled with a with a
deft touch and my biggest criticism of
the last Jedi is that it tries to do
that with like [ __ ] Thanos his glove
on bigger is like that entire middle
stretch when you go to the [ __ ] can't
he'll bite you on this casino pun it's
all about like
the privilege and haves and have-nots to
look these [ __ ] animals are being
slaved for our pleasure and like it's
it's really heavy-handed and it's slow
and it has no real functional story
purpose it's just I want to talk about
inequality for 40 minutes in a Star Wars
movie it was like you could cut that out
entirely and the movie still works so
that felt like an indulgence on Ryan's
part they're like I just want to talk
about a thing in a Star Wars movie and I
think in Roger Skywalker it's done as
part of the fabric of it like who are
you how did you get here
how did you get to be one of the one of
the part of the rebellion oh we were
just like you and with Eric's tiny
rewrite I think that just hammers at
home of like oh we were inspired by you
fn-2187
to the movies in terms of like I'm Finn
and I hang out with these cats and we do
[ __ ] together but like people were
inspired by his action and that's like
what helps the rebellion as well yeah
that's cool one of my favorite scenes in
in Return of the Jedi is when Luke
returns to help assault on Endor right
like the way they're gonna launch a
shuttle at we're gonna go down I want to
UM part of that landing party too and
the reverence of everybody's face when
they see Luke Skywalker walking into
that room because he's the guy that
[ __ ] killed a Death Star he's the guy
went mano-a-mano again throne Vader he's
the guy who gave up a hand for this
fight he's the guy who's the best of us
who's struggling with [ __ ] just like we
are and to get that moment from Finn
where it's like no man you're you're a
[ __ ] legend
yeah would be amazing because there are
legends good you win a game pick one of
these horrible games BAM from the good
folks at plays storm smell my finger a
big fat card on game I'm which whoa I
did that oh my god you're gonna turn a
game away in the movie even though I am
staring down the barrel of the [ __ ]
camera like he's there for sure like a
chump
he's that like the Dormouse he wakes up
and then goes back to sleep in the movie
who we got next what's your name man
David ever give it up a day there so
I had two scenes that were most
impactful to me when one was on top of
the Star Destroyer when they had the
land assault I really loved how they
just like they orchestrated all that
into that but then the more impactful
emotionally was I was thinking that
c-3po was gonna get deleted and I was
ready to embrace it honestly when I saw
that I was like oh that's the ultimate
sacrifice right there all right and even
like you know but Kenny Baker tension
that he had with have to be Daniels and
like you know but then bringing it right
back saying like we were friends weren't
we yeah yeah yeah it was really sweet
the only thing about like I feel I was
there when they shot that scene of
wiping his memory and I remember being
like home I got but it wasn't till I got
home where I was like this is the second
time this [ __ ] memories been
wiped at the end of the prequels like
wipe the droids like what so like it
would have been nice if like after he
came back online
they had him [ __ ] go deeper and
remember everything where it was like
Darth Vader made me like I know how to
beat these [ __ ] it was but it was
yeah I dug that as well they Anthony
Daniels they gave him some more meat
this time than they have in the previous
flicks and it was emotional [ __ ] like
you know griping him and then also I
thought it was a lovely have-your-cake-
and-eat-it-too you get to kill c-3po and
then have him come back to life and be
like I am c-3po and from the other lines
that were familiar with when we first
meet him from the first movie and then
later on they you know r2 gives them
everything back in steps so once again
yeah every box is ticked so like even if
you were like what they wiped c-3po
don't worry he's gonna get his memories
back as well they kind of covered all
the bases yeah I hate it yeah that was
come in come on Mike nobody's gonna
[ __ ] hear that say they recorded to
the light toward his memory until the
end of force awakens so he doesn't
remember just remember that yet that
seems like another [ __ ] you Terry hey
John
are you [ __ ] serious yeah that is the
last time he saw r2d2 he didn't see r2d2
and last day the level of shade that I
didn't even [ __ ] smell man wow that's
crazy
what I don't think there'd be a backup
though that's true yeah I hated him
getting his memories back yeah I really
did you like what was there was no
sacrifice yeah it's like I'm willing to
give up all of you because I believe in
this mission I and if this is the only
way for us to get there I will lay
myself down on the [ __ ] wire for this
it doesn't change the fact that he did
it except that now there's no
repercussions for him doing it because
oh oh no our cheese got back up so it's
all fine
let him have his sacrifice let him be
that hero and let it count let it let it
like just carry you through no fee even
in last Jedi what did he do in last Jedi
does he have a moment or anything it's
not memorable to me so apparently again
it doesn't matter he's like I don't
remember that movie so will he remember
the events of rise of Skywalker no just
from when he gets it all his memory back
oh no he would because r2 just gave him
more memory but he would remember
because he was like hello I'm c-3po so
everything from that moment for all the
remembers is Babu Frick and then like a
bunch of everything that happened after
Babu Frick and he was like he's he's
cute but he's no baby Yoda I'll tell you
that much he was an incredible droid
Smith though he was a great droid Smith
man and as finally before the movie was
over we got to see somebody droid
cracking and [ __ ] like that is that it
you win a game look it up well done my
friend one or the other
beautiful what do we got next JC hi
Kevin
hi there so you guys started to really
get into what I thought was most
important hi Ken I just said howdy
captain all right what's your name Kara
song Tom give it up for Tom man it's Tom
he said I can I was like oh he knows him
[Music]
so the thing that got me about this
movie and I love this movie right I'll
let this movie feeling good and really
one of the things that made me this
movie was well you guys started to talk
about when Luke raised red five
yes that to me was the conclusion of the
Skywalker Saga in Empire Luke couldn't
believe that that could be done but Yoda
was telling him you know you have to be
you have to you have to forget what
you've learned and Luke wasn't able to
do that through the first trilogy and in
this movie he went when she threw the
start the lightsaber into the fire and
he caught it and all that was really an
fu to the Jedi mm-hmm what he was there
to do was say I've learned this I
finally learned what Yoda was here to
teach me and that was to let go and when
he raised red five that was his ability
to do what he could never do in life in
life yeah and that was why I you know
and so when Leia finally disappeared
when Luke was gone that was that was it
she was saying well it's done it's
finally finished
this saga is done he's learned what he
needs to learn and the saga is done and
so JJ's idea of this will wrap up the
Skywalker little saga was all wrapped up
in that moment and that was it for me
that's all I needed
that's all I needed from this movie and
I think that really sort of Ryan
Johnson's movie it's up yeah and I'd
only appreciate it after I left suddenly
you were able to be like oh yeah like
[ __ ] that yeah that's what did it
yeah and so
since when did force ghosts get this
[ __ ] powerful and if they're always
this [ __ ] powerful in general they
didn't return the Jenna [ __ ] all the
time yeah it's a little bit like the dr.
Manhattan the more powerful you make
them the more in question like why
didn't you do more [ __ ] man well you
know that's that's sort of something
that happens throughout the the sequel
trilogy I mean you know force healing is
the same as the question that you're
asking
oh yeah like if Yoda could have been the
whole dough Lewis is also that yeah like
that could have solved everything in the
in the original trilogy right yeah yes
okay to force healing right I mean I
feel like the whole dole maneuver which
I love that terminology is a thing that
like she thought of at the moment and
nobody had thought of before because
nobody was dumb enough to do that with a
[ __ ] starship well you know I agree
with that and I think that that's kind
of a ridiculous ridiculous to think that
no one thought of that before then or if
not know if people have thought of it
nobody did it you know like is it again
the first time we've seen it but like if
force ghosts can start doing [ __ ] like
lifting x-wings then like guys you're
all here like let's all do some [ __ ]
like why are we not knocking down a
dance when we can be with me fighting
these [ __ ] yeah but good thing is it's
the last movie so we never have to yeah
and Ray was able to lift I don't know
how many stones in Jedi she lifted but
Luke was only able to let three yeah so
she's way more power yeah and that sort
of flies in the face of what the force
is supposed to represent at to a Jedi
lifting rocks yeah yeah exactly
that was beautiful point man you win a
game come up and get one tom well done
give it up
yeah who's next
what's your name captain I am Dylan
Dylan gave it up for Dylan man um my man
just switched out he's like I do not
want smell my finger can't bring this
home what do you got Dylan you know man
I'm like a basic Star Wars fan like I
love the movies I go and check them out
other other people try and school me on
them all the time so I'm like I know
what's up and then other people are like
we'll talk about the fight obi-wan
Kenobi and Anakin Skywalker and they
don't know the plan I'll be like
Mustafar okay I know some [ __ ] but not
too much casual fans yeah more than
casual because you name some places yeah
I know some some of the places start
with that so I'm familiar with this see
in the movie the first time I think I'll
wait to stone because listen I saw the
flick if you guys are all gonna the
flick I'm watching she goes off throw in
there like the tools you need you have
all the hold on one sec wherever a
little sound as you take that one got
all the tools you need and then she
grabs the wayfinder and I'm like and
destroyed that [ __ ] I'm like oh [ __ ]
what am I talking about she [ __ ] bit
now although I did say oh I was like you
want to give in mind for the time thing
I'll reach probably that's it here toss
it over
we did it so anyways yeah so he he tells
her she has everything she needs and
everything like that and I'm sitting
there going how she doesn't have the
wayfinder and then I'm realizing I'm
high as [ __ ] and I didn't realize the
last five minutes she took off after
defeating kylo Ren in kylo Ren ship so
I'm sitting there going now great
alright I gotta go see this [ __ ]
Saturday before Kevin Smith so so I go a
second time and whatnot I watched the
movie and I'm like you know what decent
flick it wasn't overly epic but I give
it a decent I give it a decent review as
just a casual fan I thought it was
awesome you know especially in a year
where endgame just came out everyone's
just gonna want some space battle that's
gonna try and compare with that one but
you know what it is what it is it's a
good flick I give it a thumbs up and
earlier you're talking about when they
came down which you've rather had Keri
Russell say were not alone
other than know I wanted kylo Ren solo
to do that I mean and I like to carry
Russell character like I like what it
says about like you know we've all got a
history well been somewhere before we
chose to come here but but yeah and like
listen nothing in this movie looks bad
like it's not like they got to replace
the [ __ ] cat hands because they
didn't do it right the first time I want
to see the shitty cut like everything is
gorgeous I mean it's it's this is the
state of the art state of the art work
and so when you see fields of [ __ ]
starter stories it looks amazing when
you're having this [ __ ] you're
crawling around the inside of Return of
the Jedi and it's broken
it's beautiful like everything is
beautiful the things that I just always
want it's just a little bit more
emotional resonance a little bit more
depth a little bit more like here's the
way that we break your heart for real
and not just by giving you a thing that
you remember when you were eight but a
thing that like you can just take with
you from here on out so yeah it's less
about it's less about how awesome it is
and more about how deep it is because it
is awesome like literally to look at it
it fills you with awe yeah how did we do
this yeah it's that was it
I like that oh my god from Averett from
somebody who's just like this ain't my
religion this is movies that I see and
I've seen them all I was gonna say I
like flicks man and I thought it was a
good flick although as a casual movie
goer I was happy with them showing
Palpatine right off the bat I was like
about two hours how long we gonna
[ __ ] wait and then right off the bat
I was like I'll give you props for that
I felt the same way I was like I was
like wow they're gonna make us wait
until the third act and right up front
they're like here's our Palpa dick and
they just whipped it out like let's get
this out of the way look how [ __ ]
cruddy it looks and [ __ ] I thought that
was a smart move - I appreciated that
the dead do speak the dead do speak I
thought that was [ __ ] funny and they
call it the dead speak it's like a
headline and [ __ ] you win a game come
pick one up man give it up man
excellent job man oh yeah next what's
your name sir my name is Tim so I had
two thoughts the first one being that it
just to recognize the brilliance of John
Williams in this the last Star Wars
soundtrack that he will ever write
absolutely and he got a cameo yeah he
was in the bar with his eye patch and
everything yeah that was great
the other thing was kind of going off to
the c-3po I loved how he even he was a
little bit in last Jedi and you know
late it was like you know that
ridiculous you know shock face or
whatever off but I loved how like we
haven't seen him too much in the
previous two and then this one he was
all the one-liners all the way through
like Oh Baba the Freak one of my oldest
friends because he's been a you know
this memory for like ten minutes so but
I thought that like in his journey and
him being integral to the like the story
just allowed him as opposed to r2 who
was almost always integral to the story
and these other droids
while c-3po was kind of just there as
you know I'm a companion and gay really
gives Anthony Daniels after four to two
years being a part of every single movie
except for solo like a good send-off a
great send-off absolutely agreed and
also like a career best performance I
thought
and then seen you felt like oh [ __ ] the
gravitas of like shutting him down yeah
yeah he carried it and they did honor
him and he has been there every step of
the [ __ ] way like you know now we've
got a gazillion different droids and
they added a new one who do I think it's
i think that's JJ's it's JJ's voice yeah
so like you know every day they've
introduced BBA and then here's another
even [ __ ] cuter droid and [ __ ] and
you forget we begin the journey with two
droids who in 1977 we were all like I've
never [ __ ] seen anything like that
right that one's adorable and whatever
he's got a friend but [ __ ] oh my god
this is fantastic
and you know the droids have played
varying roles as you said in last Jedi
that wasn't much so it wasn't really
much for c-3po for Subway kazoos like
yep you're wondering why I have a red
arm and a red leg that was it so this
one they gave him a lot more to do game
few like big [ __ ] moments and made
him feel like he was part it's true
generally r2 is the big [ __ ] hero
right so having him have the message in
him was kind of dope yeah and for me
like I literally do not remember the
first time I ever watched Star Wars it's
just been that ingrained in my life my
you know the entirety of it so I loved
this film and I've even saw it twice in
12 hours at 1:30 a.m. Thursday night and
then I with my parents [ __ ] because I
just loved it true blue yeah
favorite part Oh probably wet like when
they showed wedge antilles and that
whole thing I was like yes he's there
and just like the little cameos he's
been at every important [ __ ] battle
yeah it was cool can I ask you guys a
question yeah there's a flashback I
think it's a flashback to when Ray gets
taken from her parents
yeah is the character who does the
taking is that Maz Kanata no that's
unkar plot that was the guy that Simon
Pegg played right like I need this is
worth one half yeah one portion that was
Simon Pegg yeah there was like that
like a younger less wrinkly a little
taller - boy and and in the original
ensure gets that vision when she touches
the lightsaber and you see that flash
like the first time you kind of hear him
go like stay with me girl like don't run
away kind of a thing as she's yelling
out to her parents being good yeah he
does your voice again what do you think
Simon Pegg was also the British guy who
looked like Blue Devil from DC Comics
was like no war you know it could have
been they also could have been I blink
on k2s oh hell onto it alle Juden
because you know he just comes in it
does these random voices and then goes
away I could just see Simon doing it
just because the him and JJ are kind of
tight and stuff and that was a kind of
substantial small bit yeah you got
anything else no that was that you win a
game come get it man well done well done
and thank you for supporting this little
independent film by going twice they
could use all the help they can get oh I
can do that as well what's your name sir
my name is Samuel give it up for Daniel
Samuel Samuel sorry okay
thank you for watching I just wanted
like comments on like what a class act
JJ did with like the ending like just
like the two moons on Tatooine just like
for me like like I'm my first Star Wars
experience was when I was little it was
episode 1 watching little Anakin on
Tatooine like in the unjust Tatooine
like and with the two moons and
everything and and so like just ending
it there and then and then also when I
grew up and I watched the older ones
like I'd like Luke on Tatooine like just
ever it's just he ended it where it
started literally for like every
generation like yeah so it just live but
for your generation to Tatooine places
yeah so I just thought that like he's
such a class act to do that and then my
one of my favorite parts was like the
gold lightsaber I've never seen
something like that and like one of my
favorite colors is gold and I've always
like wondered like are there like any
other different colors of lightsabers so
like that was just like epic to me like
a gold frickin lightsaber also the
introduction of leh
had a lightsaber yeah that's who's yeah
brand-new information and also yeah well
including the sequence where he flashes
back to like it was the last night of
her training and you're like he trained
his [ __ ] sister and then she [ __ ]
knocks him on his ass he's ready to go
and like that all that [ __ ] was really I
loved in the movie when principle when
Leia general Leia walks away and Ray
says yes monster yeah when they she
revealed like she is her master at this
point she's the [ __ ] in Padawan and I
had a point to make about Leah's death
kinda because in that flashback scene
Luke said that she sensed her death
would happen or her son's death would
happen at the end of her Jedi journey
well the end of her Jedi journey was
when Ben gave up his life force for for
Rey to come back to life and so and then
right at that point after the kiss and
everything then her body disappears and
right after that Ben's body disappears
boom and like hurts her Jedi journey
ends and her son died so it just
confirmed what Luke was said that's
pretty good wait a sec I got fingered
through you know the tracks that does
track [ __ ] well done yeah gets to be
a force ghost okay so now she achieved
her Jedi journeys done so and her so
then does kylo not to get to be a force
ghost because I just think it was too
soon like maybe I yeah he's gotta wait a
little bit long yeah I mean his body
does disappear which seems to be yeah
yeah usually is that I think I don't
know why they didn't do it I think it
would have been cool to do kylo there
too because like like at the end of
Return of the Jedi they had they didn't
they redo it with like Anakin Anakin
instead of the old yeah and so like I
think they could have done Ben Kenobi
and again and Yoda Yoda it yeah so yeah
I mean look again like [ __ ] we could
pick EU in the whole night but I'm like
I don't see there's other than like he
can't be a force ghost because he's not
a Jedi [ __ ] that the yeah there's no
reason they couldn't have had yeah
Hans standing there with Luke and Leia
well and there's your [ __ ] last shot
but I think they honored you know Canon
is that the idea Jay Jay see why am I
asking you you don't even [ __ ] know
man yeah what do you mean where's an
expert you're like I don't know if I
wanted to be nitpicky and I wanted Han
Luke and Leia in the frame yeah maybe
would have done it during the flashback
when we saw young Luke and young Leia
you could have D aged Harrison and put
those guys on screen in that frame
that's [ __ ] cool too man holy [ __ ]
we're all talking about the movie they
didn't make and you or there's also no
reason that when when Leia if Leia is
the one who sends the image of Han to
been she were to send the image of Han
and herself and Luke Skywalker so that
they're all there nobody's a force ghost
they're all manifestations of whatever
and you get them all on the same page
mmm memories yes I like the younger
version of Jedi intervention nice video
game do that [ __ ] off camera is that all
you got that's great come get a game you
won give it up for a man great job
excellent insight one more game wins
you've got one question left man pick
wisely JC somebody going homeless smell
my finger game what's your name my name
is Derek what is it Derek everyone give
it over there I'm gonna get up to my
wife
quick who made the baby Yoda's because
you either wife made the baby Yoda yes
there with him man get up on camera show
the world the talented face behind she
this damn adorable baby Yoda two days
ago we were sitting on the couch and I
mentioned like Oh ivory you know once in
a while people bring stuff for Kevin and
Mark and you know you've made these baby
Otis for people it would be really cool
if we had one for them and I said it
more of a joke but she'd busted her ass
and how many days ago oh [ __ ] you did
both baby odors in one day yeah I did I
actually worked on one of them when I
saw Raisa Skywalker again you worked on
in the theater yes so you were like
doing this [ __ ] while the movie's going
on that's [ __ ] adorable man I think I
can do any my god thank you man I
thought you made like a hundred and you
just gave us two but you made it just
for us I mean twelve twelve no you gotta
keep going man [ __ ] look at that [ __ ]
who don't want one I will totally not
put that on eBay
this shit's going right on my goddamn
shelf at any time anyone's like hey man
baby I'm like look at this beautiful
thank you for that um so like most
people before Rises Scott Walker came
out we re watched everything and when
the last Jedi came about it kind of hit
me that the last Jedi has so many
moments that stand out to me as some of
like the best in the series like the
firt the first battle in the last battle
are outstanding and everything with
cancer bite I just checked Facebook or
went on Instagram and just kind of
looking back on it now it's got the
highest of highs and the lowest of lows
for me and with rise of Skywalker I
didn't really feel that same height or
that same depth like the the lightsaber
battle that you have in the foot or the
in the wreckage of the Death Star was
awesome because it was a great
lightsaber battle and they had force
jumping and all those things that you
don't necessarily see in all the other
movies but I kind of walk away with it
just being not necessarily happy with
everything
that happened in the movie but I'm happy
with where it ended up and the movie
ends with Rey and her lightsaber and I
walk out of the theater thinking when
are we gonna get Ray's story you know we
just spent a trilogy with these new
characters but everything they did was
tied to these old characters that we
know and love so what can we do with Rey
moving forward so I guess I have less of
a statement more of a question of Corona
what can we do with Rey now because you
know again and literally everyone is
dead and now she can kind of rebuild
what she wants snap set up this show
about the beginnings of this
force-sensitive community that's out in
the world that didn't know what to do
with it Rey is the last [ __ ] Jedi
right like raised the one who can train
them all ray gets to be Luke Skywalker
for a new generation and teach them the
ways of the force and run them through
the training course wherever she decides
to set one out but I think if if she's
down and the way that apparently John
boyega isn't - like I'll go do a TV show
I'll be I'll [ __ ] Nick Fury on my way
through this TV show I'll do the first
episode I'll drop in like an episode 8
and I'll be back again for the finale
and just pay me and like it gets to be
like a lower decks version of like Jedi
Academy like what happens in this school
where everybody's got [ __ ] powers hmm
that's kind of sweet now like your show
you can have my money thank you thank
you very much what would I do with right
I'm in charge of a ratio yeah I wanted
to be successful
it's [ __ ] Rey and baby Yoda every
episode over and over again who's
teaching who the force will fly now how
do I know that's true no she is the most
powerful being in the Galaxy at this
point right she could have been the new
Emperor instead she's like you know
[ __ ] the Emperor of the Jedi's or
whatever [ __ ] she's got all the power
what do you do with that character what
do you do with the most powerful person
in the world generally you crucify them
if I remember my
I just did it with dr. Manhattan's
boilers
I don't know I don't know what I would
do with red to that point baby Yoda and
that timeline isn't a baby anymore he's
old a shioda no probably just like teen
young really young for his species they
still haven't named that species right
nope no we're in Cannon he's not like
the gill flings or whatever the [ __ ] so
I was like petulant teenage you know
just [ __ ] you yeah jerking off I am
that's why he wants the gear shift
that's awesome that was great
observation do you have anything else
great question rather no that's it don't
need anything else you gave us baby Yoda
given up firm they win the last game you
get to smell my [ __ ] finger thank you
and thank you for making those that's
adorable [ __ ] fantastic my wife
cannot have this yeah you're gonna
create a fight for mark tonight he's
gonna get home and his wife gonna fight
over the baby like he could have been in
my stocking I'm like yeah I coulda but
it wasn't even better just put it in the
stock and be like I made well we sat
around and we talked about this movie
until we're blue in the face and then we
heard other people talk about it
when we announced this show the other
day we thought maybe 30 people show up
but you all [ __ ] sold it out did you
have a good time tonight ladies
I can't thank enough for being here
ma'am but the guy who had the ideas the
guy standing next to me give it up for
the great mr. mark Bernard we we are not
back together for a good long life oh my
god so this is not only the last show of
the year
this is the last fat man beyond of the
decade-- of the decade-- and we don't go
back until when I think you're back in
the world in early March late fed you
know I think I come back weaker that's
why if we could probably do a show that
yeah I mean look I'm sure while I'm gone
you'll be [ __ ] taken over and it won't
be [ __ ] Batman Beyond it'll be black
man all over like that so you'll keep
the home fires burnin
I already got the first show lined up so
yeah keep them lined up all through
January like the week of January 20 21st
22nd I'm here in town before I go up to
Sundance for a few days to do the IMDB
stuff there so maybe we could do one
there head office tell me when you're
back I will yeah and the meantime
[ __ ] hammer don't hurt him [ __ ] a
great job I got a good one on the 14th
what is it
Ellen is that snorts another year the
first one of the years here at all Majin
is the first black man beyond of 29 20
25 20 20 is gonna be what whoo January
14th one guest is coming back in a brand
new one I will have a pair of Battlestar
Galactica veterans with me ooh
Tricia Helfer who could not make her
previously appointed task is going to
make her debut behind the bar oh [ __ ]
and she's bringing Katee Sackhoff with
her oh yeah so shoeshine and or Starbuck
Starbuck yeah Tricia promised me a
threesome and she's delivering a three
yeah all right so that is when the 14th
Tuesday of the 14th of January
Tuesday 14 tickets on sale now yet soon
they will be and go pick up tickets for
that also
the J and saw Bob reboot Roadshow tour
continues ladies gentlemen on the road
as of January 10th to Oakland Fox
Theater in Oakland
tickets at Reba
Roadshow calm we tour until February I
have 25 more cities to go to before
we're done we finished February 26 which
is the one-year anniversary of when we
started shooting the movie Oh see how
that works so you can come see me on the
road and whatnot and see the movie with
me what else can I tell you go out right
now if you haven't already and see rise
of Skywalker's you heard from a few of
us we've seen it multiple times and
whatnot I'm not saying do this to help
the movie it needs your help they don't
need [ __ ] help their Disney their
Star Wars they can make all the money
and [ __ ] but they finished something
there's a big conclusion man is a year
of [ __ ] finales Game of Thrones ended
[ __ ] the Avengers saga temporarily
ended this is [ __ ] ending and [ __ ]
like that me I opened up the view of
skew diverse I'm like no I'm back
nothing ending we're here but a lot of
big endings going on man so check this
one out this is huge cinematic [ __ ]
event anything you want to add I don't
man I mean if you care the slightest bit
Star Wars the slice - but Star Wars you
can owe it to yourself to see this
because it is it is the finale it is the
the last version of this story we're
gonna get and regardless of my mid picks
or my like sort of feelings about scenes
and whatever it's an important [ __ ]
moment in the life of a nerd is to watch
something end and end with some sense of
style and some sense of grace and some
sense of love for sure well [ __ ] put
man give it up for mark he said
something nice
but most importantly thank you to
everybody who shows up to this show
weekend we go we love the people who
watch at home and stuff folks who can't
be here and stuff but being here in the
room and you see so many the same
familiar faces all over again and it
makes you feel like family you know part
of the this story of rides of Skywalker
at least that I got out of it was that
you know you don't get to pick your
[ __ ] family like she was related to
Palpatine she's like oh [ __ ] that so you
do get to pick your family sometimes
you're not the you know you don't want
to hang with the family you were [ __ ]
born to and [ __ ] you build your own
family and stuff we have built our own
family here in this very space man
week after week you all keep coming back
and supporting us and I can't thank you
enough it's one of my favorite things in
the world to do this show and it sucked
being away for so long not being able to
do it but we got to do it three times in
the span of a week now between the show
at the [ __ ] Chinese and in the show
here the other day and then the show
tonight and stuff and I can't thank you
all enough for being here man thanks for
making us feel like we got something to
say every week cuz lord knows we do but
you make us feel like there's somebody
there to hear it man as the year comes
to a close as the decade comes to a
close thanks everybody for coming out
thanks to JC for giving us a place to do
this [ __ ] show thanks to the people
at home for watching the [ __ ] show
and thank you to this guy who makes the
[ __ ] show for me man like you know
this shows taking on a few different
permutations and whatnot this is
obviously my favorite version of the
show because we've done this version the
longest and stuff and that's because
every week I get to learn a little bit
something standing next to you mostly
I'll learn you don't like nothing well
yeah but what I learned is how things
could be better and how story could
change and be more effective and stuff
like that not only am i entertained I
have a good time but I also walk away
like a better creator every time i watch
this show so thank you for that much no
that's very
that is fat man beyond for this week man
I'm Kevin Smith mark Reynaldo tune in
next year named fat time same fat
channel SModcast car more youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith may the force be with
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you